Four three,
two,
one.
And we're live teddy atlas.
Thanks for being here man.
I really appreciate it.
My Dad keeps saying that.
Stop make you guys listen to
anyone out there mad at you.
No one's mad at anything.
There's no real set time.
You know,
I can't,
I got to tell you,
since I announced you're
going to be on the podcast,
I had about a hundred people
tell me to get you mad.
They want you to rent,
get scraped.
Every sunset,
we're firemen speech
you gave to Tim Bradley.
Everybody wants you to
start screaming to get mad.
You get,
you get people hyped up.
Believe there is only an occasion flood.
And I don't think there'll be an occasion.
Um,
I,
I'm looking at this stuff here.
You've got a nice place here by the way.
Thank you.
And it's making me think about
the Denzel Washington movie.
Uh,
the equalizer,
the first one where it was
in with those Russian guys.
So were like messed up guys.
And he was trying to
protect that girl and he,
he started pointing,
there were skulls and
stuff at the guy's desk,
you know,
and uh,
he was pointing the stuff he was
trying to explain to the guy,
listen,
let this girl go,
you know,
I'll give you $9,000.
Whatever was let her go.
She was like 15 years old.
And,
um,
he,
he didn't want to listen to him.
And so he started the head
stuff like this with the skull.
I don't know if the people could see it,
but um,
and he started pointing
it towards him and I,
the guy didn't like take the hint,
you know,
the guy.
Then a couple of minutes later
he killed everybody in the room,
but it's just,
it looks exactly like the thing from
that movie to Denzel Washington where he,
uh,
he also had guns and stairs right there.
There's a scene.
This is Jamie pulled the scene.
Oh really?
He was fair.
I never saw that movie.
Yeah.
So you see like it's a scene
where he starts pointing,
they might've taken this from here.
I mean,
they could've gotten it from us,
from Mexico who props.
Um,
so they,
they pointed,
he pointed at all towards the guy to kind
of warn the guy what was coming next.
But
that's probably the only good movie that
ever came out of a terrible TV series.
You remember the TV series?
The equalizer?
I remember the name,
but I don't know that I ever really
watched it.
I was a fat,
sloppy white guy driving a Jaguar that's
supposedly kicked everybody's ass and
you'd watch it and you know,
get the fuck out of here with this movie.
I didn't watch it.
I heard a TV show.
It was a just a dumb TV show
that didn't make any sense.
And when they turned it into a movie
and had Denzel Washington in it and I'm
like,
what?
How is this possible?
Because he freaking out.
Not really,
but like,
I was just thinking about that then.
So listen man,
you were,
you just came back from
the Canelo triple g fight,
which was a phenomenal fight.
That was a phenomenal fight.
I really enjoyed that fight a lot.
We'll
exaggerate how good fights nowadays.
Like,
if they're around,
everything's great.
Everything.
If a pitcher has one
good year in baseball,
he's great and he's,
he's like the next Sandy Colfax.
Like people don't wait to see and,
and truly graded,
uh,
against things that were
out of their IRA because,
you know,
we're human.
Like,
Hey,
I was there.
I reported on it.
It's the greatest fight ever.
And No,
no,
but that's what people
will do what they do.
I think it was a really good fight,
but everything's relative,
you know,
and it depends on
everything is influenced.
The judgment of people is influenced,
at least how I see it in my field
for whatever that's worth by.
What's around and how long were they are?
Like everybody bought to Pacquiao,
Mayweather first fight
because the fans were hungry.
Their imagination was like,
there's no good fights.
There's going to be a good fight.
So they'll,
they're anticipating it.
So you got them at the right time.
If it was the 80s and you had Lenin Duran,
porno would've gone Hagler Hagler uh,
you know,
you had,
um,
Hearns,
I mean,
you had all these great fight.
Aaron Pryor,
he had all these guys fighting each other.
You probably couldn't have
pulled off the Mayweather
Pacquiao thing that you pulled
off and it turns out to be,
you know,
a,
a bit of a,
I don't want to say scam,
but it definitely wasn't what it lived
up to be because back Ya'll came into the
fight injured.
I don't believe it.
I never saw any listener.
I'm going to tell you
needed to have an injury,
but you,
you're in a tough position.
You wouldn't taekwondo and all that kind
of fighting stuff in Lma and whatever
part of it.
I'm probably not giving it a proper
understanding of what it was and,
and exactly what part of the fighting,
not just my,
maybe I'm being too broad,
but I know you did taekwondo,
you did kickboxing.
I know that you're,
you are national champion
when you were young.
Somebody show me some more about it.
So,
um,
you,
you do things when you're injured.
I mean like when are you not injured?
If you're,
if you're a football player,
if you're a fighter,
if you're in the contact button,
tell me when you're not in jail,
like when there's not something wrong.
So I never saw proof during that bout
I was there covering it for ESPN.
I never saw proof where he went store or
he didn't fold that hand or he threw it
in a,
in a poor way or in a,
in a less than high level way.
I never saw that.
So listen,
I'm not in his body.
Uh,
you know,
and,
and um,
I'm not a mind reader,
but I didn't see it.
But what I did see,
I saw him in his trainer in the runway
was more telling to me taking selfies
because they had got paid a few extra
dollars to promote some kind of product
where the selfies were attached to it.
So I saw that,
to me that was more debilitating to see
a guy before the biggest fight of his
life where people were going crazy and
going to break the paper view record and
paying $100 for the freaking thing,
to see him taking a selfie when the
mentalities should be in a different place
and normally is in a different place
before you're about to walk that hundred
yards to the ring where you
might not come out of there,
it's always possible.
You have to have that mentality.
I thought that was more debilitating
than anything I saw physically with what
was supposed to be an arm injury.
So to me,
look,
to me,
maybe it's,
I don't know if it's fair
to say was a money grab,
but obviously it was
a bit of a money grab.
Ah,
they were beyond themselves.
Uh,
you know,
one guy was retired,
he came back forward.
They were beyond the peak of
their abilities in their career.
And I just,
I just didn't see,
uh,
I,
I didn't see that fight.
Uh,
the purpose to it.
Well,
it happened about five,
six years late.
Yeah.
I just,
I mean,
what,
what I,
I you,
everyone who gets in the ring,
they deserve to make as
much money as they can.
I never,
I never say that a fighter got overpaid.
Never.
I don't care.
I never say that because I understand
what it took to get to that point and,
but you know,
you can,
you can play with things and you know,
you can kind of lead people to things.
And again,
where we started with this conversation,
you know,
it,
it's the time you are around the,
the environment.
What's not around,
not just what's around
but what's not around,
you know,
not that many great fights
to be made right now.
So what you're saying,
so in triple g Canelo fight is important
because there's not a lot of guys
waiting in the wings.
It's not like the old days of the 1980s
are the glory days of the welterweight
in the middleweight division.
No,
it's not.
And the people,
you know,
they,
they have a thirst,
if you will,
to see something that the
PR department can bring.
It can use the right
material because they,
it has to be fighters that obviously a
marquee fighters with a name that they
can build it and get the
imagination of the people to say,
this is going to be a great one.
So when they see it and
they pay $100 on $85 or $95,
whatever the heck they're playing,
um,
for the fight and then it's a good fight,
well becomes a great fight
because of all those elements.
Because uh,
you know,
it's during your time you saw it,
you committed to it,
you sacrifice to pay that money,
you sacrifice a fly there and yeah,
it's a really good fight,
becomes a iconic and,
and I don't think we
separate that in our minds.
I don't think,
hey,
who says we have to,
because right.
It's about enjoyment.
So if that,
if that makes people happy,
hey,
that's part of,
that's part of what goes into
the mix of entertainment.
But I didn't see it when I tried to
separate that being in the business.
I didn't see it as,
you know,
the Thrilla in Manila,
I used,
I saw it as a really good solid
fight and they once again,
unfortunately it took away from it.
We'd controversial with the decision.
Did you think that I thought
the first decision was terrible.
I thought triple g clearly won the fight.
I thought the second
decision was arguable.
I started like,
this is,
this looks like a draw to me.
And it was an amazing fight.
I mean,
I gotta be honest because I mean,
that's what you're supposed to be.
And who do you think one?
I added one 17 one 12 and a lot of people
going to say for you had to too fall.
I tried to pull off all week long.
I picked Canelo to win on ESPN,
on sports center.
I was working.
So I mean,
12 is big.
It's five rounds.
So I,
yeah,
so,
um,
you know,
you,
you start to,
you're human.
You start to hear people's,
like you,
you know,
that knows something about
fighting that has had the closest.
So you're,
maybe you don't want to
yell at Yaddo one 17,
one 12.
But yeah,
you still got to yell at
because that's what you believe.
That's what you saw.
And I still say it,
I still yell at that.
It was,
they didn't give him credit for gems.
Like jabs don't count no more.
Like
I'm not going to pick out anybody because
that's not really fair to do when you
have a podium and they
don't have a podium.
But
sometimes it is because they deserve it,
but not generally.
And the judges nowadays,
I think that
they just give it,
I see too often that they
almost go down the easy route.
Like you know,
they just give it to who's
aggressive for guys walking forward.
A guy's Tom Punches,
it's like their favor now.
Chi.
And it's more to it than that.
And I understand that the
sport doesn't help itself.
They don't make a clear criteria for,
but it's supposed to be clean,
harder affective punches because the
separation of professional boxing,
an amateur boxing is you have to sell it,
you have to make money and you've
got to put fannies in the seats.
So you want to see guys get hurt.
You want to see guys in pack guys.
So it's the cleaner
who hurts the guy more.
It's the cleaner,
more impactful punches,
but it's not just thrown in.
It's not just to Gretchen because
the Gretchen has to lead to something
affective affective aggression.
So I I saw for me to get it to that
one 17 one 12 I saw Goliath skin on the
outside controlling rains,
controlling distance.
You want to use that silly word ring
generalship cause I have to time,
I don't know what they're talking about.
They say ring general.
Like what?
What are you talking about?
I just saw the way you judged it.
Where,
where did,
where did you fit in ring generalship
into that into your thinking because I'd
like to know but if it is ring
generalship he was controlling range.
He was controlling outside.
He was keeping the shorter
man on the outside,
catching him with a jab,
making him earn his way in,
making them pay a price to get in.
Now was the other guy can lob and the
other guy landing the hard clean body
shots that sometimes you
don't get credit for?
Yeah,
he was all,
like I say on ESPN,
he was putting water in the basement.
Yeah,
he definitely was.
But the Jeb didn't count suddenly was
suddenly in a universe where the jab of a
guy doesn't mean anything.
When we don't want it to mean anything.
When we want to give it to
the aggressive guy to the,
to the guy trying,
you know,
trying to get in there.
The question is what,
what's more important is a jab or
important or a hook to the body.
What is more important
in your rock to the body?
Clean is more important,
more important.
But if the j about numbers to hook
to the body through many rounds and,
and the numbers are significant
that it's greater than,
then you have to account for that.
Right.
So you think that people are watching,
they're watching a couple of jabs and
then one hook to the body and they count
that one hook to the body
better than the count to chat.
Yeah.
And I don't have a problem
with that because our counted
that way till if it's a
good shot because again,
a power shot.
Yeah.
Because that is what's going
to drive people to the event,
right to the sport is a harder punches.
So I have no problem with that.
But if the jabs or 20 jabs
and it's two body punches,
well then I'm starting to save.
We can't forget the jabs because the
body punches got your attention and,
and it,
you know,
move Johnny his seat a little bit.
Maybe because for whatever reason.
So I'm just saying that the
criteria is not clean enough,
uh,
for,
for the judges sometimes
well to be even bigger mass and MMA
and it's a lot of the same judges.
I,
you mean,
I think the problem with judging
is it the same in both sports.
You should have someone who
has experienced in the sport.
I mean,
they have to have a deep understanding
of what they're actually watching.
And that's not the case.
I know it's not the case in boxing because
I know a lot of the same judges from
boxing also judge MMA.
They don't know what they're
talking about in MMA.
And I don't think they know what
they're talking about unboxing either.
And that's a real travesty.
It's a huge disservice to these
professional athletes who literally are,
as you said,
risking everything.
As they step in there,
there's a real good chance
that they might not come out.
I mean,
it happens every so many fights,
a guy dies.
This is just a fact.
And boxing and football too.
Sure.
And MMA as well.
We'll,
MMA has plenty of problems.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's less deaths in MMA,
but we're getting deaths from Wayans.
You know,
we have a lot of extreme weight
cutting issues and some of the small
organizations in particular,
all of that stuff is legitimate.
It's a problem.
Something that should be looked at.
It's just a shame that the judging is
so poor and it's been this way for so
long.
Well,
to the boxing,
I mean,
you have a,
then,
I'm not saying this in a derogatory way.
In some ways it's a good way,
but you have a dictator running,
you know,
UFC and no,
but,
but it's okay to have a dictator sometimes
because at least you have rules that
are,
he had to have structure and uh,
you know,
as long as they're not taking
people out and killing them.
I know what you're saying.
And so boxing has boxing.
He has no real
accountability,
no structure across the board.
No,
you don't real,
you know,
lateral structure and conformity,
not done unilateral because you have
different states that have different
commissions and you know,
they're supposed to be tied together,
but they all act differently and
there's no national commission.
There's no body,
there's no dictated.
There's no czar,
there's no it,
there's no NBA commissioner,
there's no NFL commissioner,
there's no MLB commissioner that
overlooks and polices the whole sport.
And
there's those separation of
church and state,
so to speak,
where the people making the
money in the sport are separated,
truly separated from the people
supposedly administrating this.
But there's no separation there.
I mean,
promoters actually that are making the
money and have obviously a horse that
running in the game,
so to speak that night,
uh,
that they won,
that fight it to when they pay the judges.
And there's no,
there's no,
again,
there's no buffer.
There's no separation where you can
have promoters and managers that can
actually go to the commission and say,
we don't want these judges to judge.
They can't say,
put this judge and,
but they can knock judge
his out and in commissions.
We'll listen to them.
Uh,
the alphabet organizations,
they're corrupt.
Um,
they are,
I mean,
it's not teddy atlas saying it.
It's everybody saying that there's very
few people who are going to say they're
not corrupt,
corrupt.
I mean,
if you're going to be honest
about it and you're not,
and you don't have an agenda where you're
afraid to say it because you have an
agenda,
which a lot of people do in my business,
they have agenda.
So then I'm going to say,
dude,
because they're part of it.
If they're not part of it,
uh,
they're,
they're friendly with
people that are part of it.
And,
uh,
they want to have access,
they want to have relationships,
they say away from it.
And,
and they understand how the culture
should work so they understand,
uh,
you know,
is it,
is it a smoky room with
cigars like the old days?
Well,
Frankie Carbo was one of the things,
and you put an anvil,
no,
it's not that,
but you might be paying
$30,000 for an ad and,
and,
and uh,
at a convention for the WBA or
the WBC or the w IBM for Wbl,
whatever the heck they are.
And you might be paying
30,000 foot and what,
what you,
you know,
why you paid the 30,000 for that?
I don't think that you just like to see,
um,
your name and add in a,
in a brochure.
There's,
there was a purpose
behind paying that had.
And um,
so there's no,
again,
okay,
you have the administrators have to sport
the commissions and then you have to
alphabet organizations that get paid
a sanction and free from the champion.
So they want that champion to win.
And so they get to sanction fee.
And especially if he's a popular champion.
So the,
so now you have
no body saying,
well the manager can't talk to the
sanction organization for modern can't.
Of course they can talk to them and say,
I want my guys rated high.
Of course they have access.
So they have access to
talking to somebody,
influencing somebody to move
their guy up in the ratings,
these honest ratings and they have
access to telling an organization,
well I,
you know,
I'd like to push a mandatory,
I like to push my guy
to get the mandatory,
which means of course,
that he's got to fight them
within a certain period of time.
He's got to fight to champion.
That was missing in MMA.
Yeah,
that's absolutely missing.
So you have all that stuff going on
and where,
where,
where's the,
where's the oversight?
Yeah.
Where's all of us?
I was the police in wisdom.
Right?
Where's the line where,
because again,
people making money,
people running the sport,
people administrating the sport.
It's not supposed to blur a,
there's supposed to be a separation now
if you know where to go in Europe or
America or United States too,
but all to Europe where there's
a lot of big fights too.
It's just a big fight with Joshua,
uh,
in London,
knee drew 90,000 people,
which is good for the sport and it's,
it's,
it's incredible.
Um,
but if you know what restaurant
to go to tonight before big fight,
you will walk in a restaurant.
I've been there,
I'm not going to say something and if I
can't stand behind it and you will see
at the restaurant,
it's all big table kind of like,
you know,
not the last supper,
but it's,
it's a big table and you will see all the
officials at that table that are going
to work to fight the next night.
And you will see the organizational heads,
the heads of that sanctioning body.
And,
and the guys are in charge.
The presidents,
vice presidents,
um,
supervisors are judges,
referees and guess who
the host of the dinners,
the promoter.
Some more with that.
I mean,
is something greatly wrong with that?
So the host of the dead end,
it's a big bill obviously.
I mean it's a lot of people.
It's a good restaurant.
The eating all the best of drinking,
the best wines and everything else.
So it's a big bill and it's being picked
up by the promoter who wants a specific
fight to win that night and he's got all,
he's got access to all the judges or the
officials or the organizational heads
now.
So I would say to the people that
are listening out there that,
just to make the analogy dead really I
think would hit home the New York Yankees
there obviously your universally known,
Our Name and brand sort of organization
maybe the biggest of all time.
So how about in New York?
You go to the best restaurant and
a night before a world series game,
you walked into the restaurant and
you saw all the umpiring cruel,
all the officials that are in charge of
the umpiring for the world series game,
sitting at a dinner hosted
by the Steinbrenner's
problem.
Problem,
problem,
problem.
Giant problem.
Yeah.
And it can't happen because there's a
commission would never let that happen
because the integrity,
the credibility of Dysport would be
down the tubes in one moment before you
could finish his shrimp cocktail.
And so it can't happen.
It happens on checked in box
thins all the time in boxing.
And just the look of impropriety is wrong.
It should be wrong.
It,
it should be wrong.
A baseball,
it should be wrong and
football should be wrong in MB,
but it should be even more wrong in
a sport where you risked so much.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
Yeah,
it's a very,
very good point.
And I don't know how
you would ever fix that.
I mean,
how would you have some
universal oversight of the
entire sport and how would
you get everybody from the Wbo w you know,
WBC,
cause they wouldn't,
no,
they don't.
Can have because the president of the
United States started Karen when there was
a problem with baseball.
He got,
he got involved.
That was about steroids though,
right?
Yeah.
But it was a problem.
But wasn't that a horseshit problem?
I mean it was a real problem.
But it was more of a problem of they
wanted to clean up the image because it's
America's sport and they had
these people that were the fence.
We're going to leave
the game a little bit.
So it was a problem.
This is a problem.
It was impacting them.
It was impacting,
loosen
w it was impacting the
perception of the game,
which impacted the,
the gates,
what they're gonna make.
And ultimately the fan base,
which of course impacts them financially
or it impacts the country because of
less people care about this sport.
Um,
you're going to see it less
and if you care about it,
you're going to be one of
the people that are left out.
So it was a problem and they can't,
I don't,
I'm going to be careful saying this,
but not that careful,
but I,
because you have to say it,
I don't think that they care as
much about the people in boxing.
I don't think they do there.
I just,
it's,
it's more of a dangerous,
dirty sport in their eyes.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the people that come
into it and everything else.
How am I going to get into all the other
stuff that you could get into that,
you know,
so popular to get into
in some ways nowadays?
You mean like racism?
Yeah.
I'm not going to get into that because
I don't want to and I don't have,
you know,
definitive things to show for that.
I just know how I,
well,
the precise,
I just don't,
she supports,
it's not,
it's not cherished the
way baseball's cherish.
When is a big fight like Canelo and
triple g people get excited and a lot of
people buy it,
but it's not necessarily thought of
as something that represents America.
And in particularly in Canelo triple g,
you're talking about two people
that aren't American to begin with.
Yes.
Yeah.
And there's a history to boxing.
No,
that unfortunately,
you know,
because I care about this
positive for my whole life.
Um,
that it's kind of,
yeah,
it's got a reputation
as being corrupt and,
and unfortunately,
fortunately and unfortunately,
like there's a pod,
the good part where the
history goes back longer,
farther than any other sport,
any other sport.
I mean,
it was the first sport in the Olympics.
It goes back further.
And it was the biggest
sport in this country,
bigger than baseball.
At one time it was that big.
I mean,
you know,
so and now it's,
it's not,
and it,
it's too bad because,
and it's too bad that the kids,
that the younger people,
they don't have the ability
to learn about those fighters,
those special fighters.
That was special.
They really want,
and it was special for different reasons.
Like,
like Jackie Robinson was special.
We know,
we don't have to go
into why he was special,
but nobody knows that Joe Lewis,
who's quiet and everything,
but when he was in the army and it was,
you know,
segregation and all that crap going on,
he,
he quietly used his position
as heavyweight champ of
the world to make sure that
when he went to movies and they,
him in the front row and he saw that
blacks weren't allowed to come in.
He said,
I'm not going in there and
let's blacks can come in there.
When he went to other sort of events
where the same kind of junk was going on,
he very quietly but powerfully
integrated things and said,
no,
I'm going to make a change here.
You,
you're not going to have me.
And I'd have people that look like me,
you know,
kept out.
So he,
and there were people I've read about
it because I like reading about those
things,
but history,
um,
to see how we could be better and then,
where we've come from.
And there were history of black families,
you know,
poor black family,
he said would,
would get hope from just saying,
hey,
Louis did it.
They would tell their kids,
hey,
listen,
I don't want to hear this.
I don't want to hear that.
You can't do this.
Joe Louis did it.
And then so he was that important.
That's all,
that's the only point I'm making here.
He was that freaking important that
that history and the history of other
fighters like him.
It doesn't have to be black fighters,
but that what they fought for,
what they did,
what they overcame,
where they came from,
who Benny Lennon.
Um,
one of the greatest Jewish
fighters of all time.
It was a time when,
uh,
and,
and it's still around,
unfortunately there's
a lot of antisemitism,
but there was a time where it,
you know,
it was tough being a Jew and,
and you're,
you're growing up and
he get caught or cake.
I don't know if I'm pronouncing right,
I think it was right and you
get caught all those kinds of,
I don't even know what the hell it means.
I just know it's a bad name to call Joe.
And,
and you had all that
stuff going on and Jews,
woman thought of being there were thought
of moving towards banking and then
they're moving towards
things will make them money.
And then later on they started doing that.
But they were the ghettos and they
were trying to pull themselves out.
And so at that era,
during that time to twenties to thirties,
the truth was some of the best fighters
because that was their way of getting
out.
But there was other,
there was another significance to be in
a Jewish fighter that a lot of the kids,
their own thought of is bringing Tufts.
So they got picked on and,
and thought of that they're going to go
more towards academic and other stuff.
So there was a weakness.
Perceived not true.
None of this stuff is used for.
So yeah.
So now all of a sudden Benny
Leonard comes along when a sports,
the biggest sport in the country and he's
the best freaking fighter in the game.
And he calmed his hair before he got in
the ring and he would come out without
it being mast.
And this was,
this guy was,
I mean he was,
he was Michael Jordan.
I mean before that stuff,
before Michael joined,
before Air Jordan,
Bill pointed,
I mean this guy was
nine only toffees zone,
only a champion puts obviously
connected to be in tough by itself.
But it was,
he was smart.
He was,
he was cool.
He had Pazazz,
he was a man and there
were Jewish families.
You don't hear about these stories,
but there were Jewish families I've read
and I've heard from people where say,
Hey,
don't let nobody pick on you.
Benny Leonard is the best
fighter in the world.
Choose a tough where we're
not just smart but tough.
Betty Leonard shows that.
So that kind of history,
that kind of pulling of people
up in many different ways,
not just economically I out of poverty,
but,
but emotionally,
mentally,
because you can be in poverty mentally,
you can be in the low place mentally.
It doesn't have to be,
you know,
financially all the time.
You know where you have holes
in your shoes and you didn't,
and you're wearing shirts that don't fit.
No.
It can be the way you feel about yourself.
That is without,
without pro parity,
with with without value.
You'll have no value for
yourself as a person.
That's the worst poverty
in the freaking world.
There's not the lower than that.
And Joe Lewis and Benny Leonard,
they were fighters.
They won't baseball players.
They pulled people out of those places.
They let people know they had value,
that their rates had value.
Their people add value,
they had value and that should be
known and you can go anywhere and,
and I'm glad you can
because I love all sports.
You can go anywhere and you can read about
the greatness of the baseball players
in the greatness of,
of course NFL hasn't
been around that long,
but the greatness of those players
and the greatness of the NBA players.
But where did the kids have a get to
read and to hear and to see about the
greatness of these people,
these fighters?
V Nowhere,
very little.
Very little.
It's not there.
Why?
Because again,
I'm not going to get into craziness,
but
the powers that be the listener,
it's not marketed properly.
I get it.
It doesn't have a commission,
so it doesn't take care
of itself the way the UFC,
the greatness about to why the UFC grew
so much as they marketing themselves in
a tremendous way.
So there's nobody,
boxing is just dead.
It takes care of itself.
It exists because it's man against man.
So it's always going to be there,
but nobody's building it.
Nobody's marketing in.
No one's feeding the monster to make it
bigger and it's a plant that's in the
corner of,
of,
of your office that doesn't get sun,
doesn't get warranted,
but it's still there.
Right,
right.
It's still,
and what I'm saying is that
[inaudible] I didn't want to yell
because now probably happy but,
but,
but it should be fed a little bit.
It should be watered a little bit
because of what I just described.
Guys,
guys like you guys who have a deep
appreciation for the history of the sport
guy,
guys who have a deep appreciation
of what it meant when Joe Louis,
Max Schmeling guys,
guys who understand what it meant when
sugar ray Robinson was the best fighter
in the world and everybody knew and he
pulled up in a fucking pink Cadillac with
a beautiful suit on
and any,
any made elevated.
He elevated people in Harlem everywhere,
but Harlem,
he had,
he owned have a Harlem,
he owned restaurants and
stores and barber shops and,
and everything.
And,
and you want it to be there because
that's where sugar ray Robinson came from.
Yup.
It was great.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a rich part of history
that really does get ignored.
Let me tell you what I was smelling.
You brought up,
you know,
a lot of his stuff and that's
why it's nice to talk about which
smelling was a hell of a fighter.
Joe Lewis was the brown
bomber was coming up.
He was undefeated and um,
Schmoley had to Greg
quote before the fight.
You know,
it's kind of like the Babe Ruth thing
that did it really happen where he pointed
out and then he hit the,
you know,
those,
those are great stories.
But,
but well,
what's the real truth behind them?
You know,
we don't know.
We don't care.
We don't care to certain point.
You know why?
Because they let us feel good.
They let us dream about possibilities
and we should all have possibilities to
dream about.
And they make somebody
feel good because you know,
the Babe Ruth one was
connected to a sick kid.
So it's a nice thing.
It's where sports can be better
than just sports than just somebody
participating in it.
It can go beyond that.
He agreed stronger than that.
And that's some of the
good stuff about it.
And so smelling the great story,
he didn't point to,
you know,
the,
to the fence,
but he said before the fight,
I see something that's my,
my ag,
my trying to be an accent for the German,
you know,
but I sound more like
Sholtz from Hogan's heroes.
I don't know why.
Every time you try to do something
like with certain ethnic,
you know,
pronunciations,
um,
you,
you sound like you go
to one of those sitcoms,
you go to one of those places,
you know,
and when I say somebody,
I think my kid,
I think my son said,
Eh,
you know,
he had watched one of them and I think
he said he sounded like Sergeant Schultz,
like from Hogan's heroes,
but,
and he said,
I see something.
And what he saw was that Louis
would jab and he would leave.
You should never leave your head on a,
on the right side because
if you leave your head,
you know,
you move your head to the right side,
you're in a path to the right hand.
You should actually finish on the left
side because then you're outside the
right hand,
your follower,
that was the right hand over here.
It can hit you on the outside.
So he had a habit of,
and he had a great trainer.
He had a habit though at that point
of leaving his head off and a right.
So smelling saw something as he said
that he could hit and we're right in.
He could time it over the gym.
Now smelling was of the ilk of the level
of the caliber wasn't just about Talon.
He could punch.
It was a good fighter,
but it was a pro.
What do I mean by that?
A lot of guys would hesitate a little bit,
same opening.
They might see it,
but it was the brown bomber
who was not going everyone out.
So they hesitate.
They will.
They were afraid.
Normal.
But people afraid of that word.
I mean it's there.
I mean without it,
we're not alive.
So he,
they might see the same thing,
but they weren't going at a pro level.
Pro Level is a guy that
can do what he has to do.
And no emotions interfere with doing it.
I mean that's my simplest way
of Webster's might not say that,
but that's what I would say.
So they might've seen the opening,
but they would hesitate just
enough and be gone the door close.
Cause it's,
it's,
it's like life.
It's moments captured moment,
lose a moment.
And,
but this guy was a pro.
He,
he didn't let that come in there
and make them hesitate that,
that fear,
he controlled it.
And if a Doberman was there,
Bang,
he was going to throw the punch.
So he did and he dropped lose a few times.
And you know,
he,
he won that fight and was around and stop,
man,
I can't even remember.
Maybe,
maybe the ninth,
but it was late in a fight,
but he had heard them and you know,
Louis was taken a beating.
So Louis Lou went on,
he won a world title and um,
he'd be Bradick for the title,
Cinderella Man,
great movie.
It was made,
you know,
he came from welfare to
be in a world champion.
That's the product story without
getting into it too much.
So he lose beach Braddock.
And had to give a percentage,
you know,
Eh,
Don King and Ara might
not been around then,
but,
but the people that taught him what
to do around taught them how to take
advantage of fighters,
told them of how,
of what options were for four
options where ever known,
you know,
Eh,
the Vladik I think,
I forget his name,
but products manager basically made
Lewis and his people agree to give them a
percentage of his purse for the
rest of his career to get the fight.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
so I mean,
you could obviously research
it and look into it presents.
So I don't know.
I listen,
I could say 10%,
but I don't want to say definitively
because I'm not positive,
but,
but there was an understanding that,
you know,
you,
you're not getting a fight otherwise.
Like you want to get the
fight now and listen to,
like I said,
you know,
not great guys,
but king and Iram,
uh,
they,
they had other guys before them that
taught them some of these moves,
you know,
that warm and so nice.
But there's always a
history of good and bad.
Sure always.
Who's good?
Well,
this is,
we get to that.
If there's a shining
star promoter out there,
I try to think about it.
But so we,
so they go and they are,
he witnessed the title and of course
the biggest sport in the country.
So all the presses there and there,
Joe Champion was not yet.
Not yet.
What do you mean not yet?
Just one of the title.
Not yet.
Not Too.
I beat that man.
He didn't even have to say his name.
Not Too,
I beat that man.
That's how much pride he had.
And listen,
he's the real deal because in his mind,
how can I be champion
if a guy knocked me out?
Right.
So when that fight took place,
I mean you talk about setting a stage,
you know,
the nowadays people say,
oh I'm on the stage is a lot of pressure,
you know,
hey,
I'm not saying it's not,
I'm not saying it,
but a lot of pressure,
you'd almost done a lot of people look in,
a lot of people,
you know,
dependent on I I lot of stuff going on,
and,
and I,
you know,
maybe I got a headache,
but Cho Lewis had world
war two on horizon,
the president of the United States
call them up and you had Nazi Germany,
he had a guy named Hitler that
that is saying that he's got,
you know,
the master race it's going
to take over the world.
Just starting that stuff was not too far
away from World War Two and you've got
all that stuff permeating in the air
and you got Louis fighting a guy who of
course,
you know,
propaganda was started by the Germans,
if you want.
Almost to me almost invented that word
because you had to propaganda minister
and you had all these terrible people
with Hitler that we're putting out to dare
the master race to this day that you
had to judge you all win situation
Olympics.
Yeah.
And now you had the biggest sport in
the biggest country and the champion of
that sport to heavyweight Joe Lewis
and he's fighting the German fighter
swelling the second time now for
the title and of course you had
Hitler and all his psycho fence
or these people that were,
their job was to promote it so to
speak and they'd come and as saying,
we will show the world that we're superior
and there's no better way to show it
then in a ring.
And so Lewis has to,
okay,
he's got it,
he's got to carry all this stuff.
I mean take about it and he's
a black guy in a catchy that,
that he still can't go to certain places,
teat and he's got to carry the whole,
he's got to carry the whole country
and not let them down in the president
because I didn't get,
we don't know if there's
a legendary story,
we don't know if it's completely true,
but supposedly the president
called him and said,
Joe,
you got to witness one for
the good guys that that's,
that's one of the legends.
I don't know if it's true,
but I know that,
I'm sure he corner,
I'm sure we called them
and Louis has to go into,
is kind of going to Yankee Stadium
outdoors and in Times Square in New York,
they used to have it set up where they
would the radio because all the fight one
radio back then and some
of them on fights on TV on.
She'll lead cavalcade of
sports and all that stuff.
Friday night fights but was coming along,
you know,
to come along.
But radio was the thing.
And so in Times Square you had
the radio speakers outdoors,
you know,
playing a fight,
podcasts in the fight.
So people are out on the streets,
they hear the radio and they hear,
you know,
Joe Loses walking into
the ring and you know,
and you got Yankee Stadium,
you've got to place four and you've got
the whole world of everything I just
described.
The good,
the bad,
the evil,
the ugly,
every thing.
It's not a movie,
it's real life.
And you got Joe Lewis and he gets in that
ring and he annihilates with all this
pressure would said that
he's got to save the,
basically the United
States in a world from,
from looking like this ugly
scorge and,
and,
and disease of the Nazi party is,
is going to take over.
The world is greater than us and he and
he single handedly has to prove that.
And he,
he goes in and he annihilates the Chi
in one round with all that stuff hanging
over them.
I think that's the greatest single
event in the history of world.
Pull that fighter,
pull out,
fight up and put it in the background.
And I think that diet,
when you talk about all the things,
the way here to talk about,
about character,
about talent,
about perseverance,
about resiliency,
about,
about caring,
about more than yourself,
about selflessness,
about strength,
when you talk about all those things
that we try to say that we care about and
that we sometimes look to,
to be,
um,
very rarely can we be that
he was all that he was all of that.
And there it is right there.
I mean,
how great is that?
And he stalked the guy,
he's talked to guy and his punches
were short and powerful and he was the
greatest finisher in the history of
heavyweight bouncing because when he hurts
you,
you didn't survive.
He got rid of you.
He put punches together and it was
short and he was always in position.
Look at his legs.
He's always a position.
You move forward.
It takes a little stub fall back to get
yourself all those punches is absolutely
beautiful.
If you wanted to teach a young
fighter how to punch correctly,
Joe Louis,
there's no better guy to Washington.
Cholos.
Did you see Joe,
what he did a minute ago?
No,
a minute ago.
Smelling.
Tried to catch him with
that same right hand.
He had knocked him out two years earlier.
Go back.
They just missed it,
but he changed.
He stepped out.
He changed his distance this time because
jaggy Blackburn who's a great fighter,
a black fighter.
He was a trainee who was a great train
and nobody hears about Jackie Blackburn
what a great fighter he was and what
a great trainee was and how he wasn't
allowed to fight white
fighters and he beat everybody.
Look at it.
Cattle love talk.
Instead of laying his head on the
right like he did the first fight,
he changed his range and he
made that right hand mess.
I look how calm he is.
Look how calm he is.
Look how focused he is.
It's beautiful.
Watch shortness of those punches.
Phenomenal watches legs,
Jo wide swaths.
How he's always in position.
Look at Atlanta.
What did we miss?
What didn't you see?
Go back.
The sides don't.
No,
the blinding jab that that sets it up.
We don't see what the gem is.
Just a dick boy,
just so we can hit it with
the right so you don't see it.
Right.
What a beautiful sidestep to right
after he lands the right hand.
Beautiful.
Look at that.
Well that's why he's the
greatest finish of all time.
Watch,
watch way finishes this guy.
What it's going to go to
the body and in the head,
right head to the body.
Right ahead to the head.
Ha.
That is so short.
And even when he's got the guy hurt,
look at the guy.
Look at that.
Phenomenal,
phenomenal.
And he did all of that with everything
we just talked about for the last 20
minutes.
Hanging over him.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's a giant piece of history
that people don't talk about it.
Doesn't that make you think a little bit,
doesn't it make you
feel something about us?
Really?
Yeah.
Well it's one of the reasons why
I'm a giants fan of the sport.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I mean,
and that,
that alone is in terms of
like historical impact.
I agree with you.
It's one of the biggest moments
in all of sports ever in life.
In life.
You know what I like about boxing?
I like a lot of things at all.
Like I don't like the administrators.
I hate them.
I know there's a powerful word,
but you know,
not every single one of them,
but I'm just saying I,
I,
I hate their weakness.
I hate that cowardice.
I do.
Because they sit outside the ring.
A lot of them,
you brought up a point,
they should have had an experience one
way or the other and they've never ever
had any,
he punched him.
And I'm not saying you to be a man,
you got to get punched.
I'm not saying any of that stuff.
It's being a man as a lot more than that.
A lot more know.
Plenty of people get
punched and then I met.
But what I'm saying is that you should
understand what it feels to a person to
put themselves on the line and to
risk so much and to risk everything
to try to get their
family in a better place.
I think there's also,
they should be a fan.
And I don't think some
of them are even fans.
No,
they're not.
And some of my,
not even like it,
they wouldn't tell you that.
Right.
But they just do it for a job.
Yeah.
And,
and what I'm saying is that
when you,
when I see these people that haven't
put them spending that place and not
everyone can be in that place.
So again,
I gotta be careful with that
if I'm going to be fair,
but for them so easily to take
something away from somebody,
see what's different for me,
why I get passionate.
And if you want to use that word,
people say Teddy,
you can get a little crazy
if it happens in baseball and the guy
beats out to 12 now you have cameras.
So you didn't use half that.
But if a guy you didn't
have replay back in the day,
the guy,
it happened a lot of times,
guy was safe and,
and call them out.
You know what?
Too Bad.
It's a,
it's a shame,
but you know what?
The next day he's going to play the game
again and he's going to be able to make
amends for that.
He and his family and he's
got guaranteed contracts.
And you know what it's going to be okay.
I mean,
was it right?
Wrong is never right.
No,
but you know what?
In the mix of things
we could overcome that.
But now you take a fighter,
same thing and the judge judges
make a mistake maybe on purpose,
whatever,
but they make a bad mistake.
The fight,
it can't go back the next day and
rectify that to fight it doesn't have a
guaranteed contract.
He only has what he can make
if he gets to that fight,
that's it for that night
because where that fight goes,
he go back to the
dug out and then come out the next day
and play again with a new uniform on.
Now he goes to the back of the line
and boxing and has to take hundreds,
maybe thousands of punches
to get back to that place.
He was to earn the right to get closer
to the exit in a business because
everyone's trying to get to the exit
to try and again what they can gain,
but their legacy for their families,
for themselves in many ways financially,
you know,
and and,
but also what's inside them that they,
that they have to prove something,
that they have to make it for
old different personal reasons.
And they're close to doing that and now
they're forced because of some crock.
Maybe it's incompetence.
It either corruption and incompetence.
Okay.
But sometimes it's corruption and they
have to go all the way to the back of the
liner.
Then I'm playing a football
game the next Sunday.
Then I played in an NBA game two days
later and they got to take all those
punches and hope,
hope
they get back to that place.
And you know what?
I seen it.
I did 22 years of ESPN boxing.
I've been with ESPN about 22 years,
but I did like 18 years,
whatever was a Friday night fights.
We did a lot of title fights.
Not to big names,
not to Canelo's,
not not to go off gins,
not the Mayweathers,
what guys that had mentors as much
to even more because they didn't have
millions of Dallas and they got this
shot and I watched them get robbed
and I saw that they never got back there.
That night was the right night for them.
That particular night,
everything worked.
Everything was perfect,
all that training,
everything came together
and they were beautiful.
They were magnificent and they were
freaking robbed and it's wrong.
It's really wrong.
And that's what they do when they do that.
But the glorious thing
of if that's not too
made up of a word,
it sounds like Gloria,
but the beautiful thing about boxing is
that with everything warm in the world,
and I hate to use this cliche,
this terminology,
but you know with life being unfair,
because I don't like to use that because,
because sometimes people nowadays for me,
they,
there's too many excuses out there.
There really are.
There's too many damn excuses.
You're in this country,
you got a chance to do something
where you don't have in other places.
But having said that,
he can feel like life's
not fair sometimes,
especially when you think about some of
the things we just talked about in a day
that's gone now.
It's not there no more,
but,
well,
Dave Lewis
and all those kind of people,
life wasn't fair.
That really,
they really had a right to use that say,
nowadays,
I don't think people have of white,
black,
purple,
they don't have a right to say that
to the extent that they did back then.
Not to the extent,
no,
they don't.
They really lose all the things
wrong or they're messed up.
People still out there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But sometimes it's too easy to use that.
Yeah.
It's just too easy.
I agree.
So,
but there was a time when
life too often was unfair.
Ruthlessly on unfair.
Really unfair.
Ruthlessly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
And when life was unfair,
boxing was around to make it fair,
and I'll tell you how.
Yeah.
On one given night.
If you worked hard enough,
if you dream big enough,
if you were tough enough and
you made yourself tough enough,
you sacrificed enough,
you became polished and savvy
enough and and technically
equipped to do things that you had and
you learn those things and you just work
yourself to the ball,
okay?
No matter where you came from,
no matter what part of the world,
no matter what,
who your parents were,
no matter what your poverty
level may have been made,
not of bed,
no matter what you had,
would,
you didn't have,
no matter what people had told you,
didn't tell you
all of that.
If you made yourself and took advantage
of that opportunity and get yourself
ready
and you were ready to
behave like a champion,
you could get in that ring on one given
night and make the world fair and have
your hand lifted,
heavy call champion of the world.
That makes boxes special.
And that's what these judges don't get.
Okay?
That kids are waiting to hear
that and they give everything,
you know,
you hear too much to crap.
Where I would dive for those
people that would die for that.
So we have people in our times,
in his world,
in his country,
and you use the right world word,
you know,
tragically,
whatever powerful words you
had just shows ruthlessly.
Yeah,
yeah.
There will people because of that word,
because of the reality of the
actions attached to that world word.
Okay.
If you told them,
listen you,
you got us to you,
you're going to have to die,
you know after this,
but you'll get to have this,
your hand will be lifted.
You will be called champion of the world.
All your people will see it and the
people you want see it and yourself,
but your die afterwards
I would give you that.
People would sign on.
That's how important that was.
That's what that stood for and then you
get judges that have no conception of
that.
I don't mean to laugh,
but no,
I learned saying they have to
have a complete conception of it,
but no feeling of what
we're talking about.
I think they're like DMV workers.
That's what I think.
I think there's a bunch of
them that are real good,
but a lot of them are just like people
that had just taken a government job.
That's what I think.
And I think it's a travesty
that they're not removed.
That's what I think when
whenever I go to a UFC and it,
like I said,
a lot of it,
the same judges,
and I see some of these,
these scores,
I want to take my fucking headset off
and throw it into the cage and scream and
flip over the table and you just kind
of take a deep breath and calm yourself
down because there's nothing you can do.
And these athletic commissions have kept,
kept these people on for whatever reason.
And you're watching a bad decision.
You watch the someone
who trained for eight,
10 weeks for this one particular fight
and years and years to get to that
position and they're getting fucked and
the getting fucked because someone just
sucks at their job and they don't care.
And this person,
they,
they're going to be there two
months from now at another fight.
And there's nothing you could do about it.
And I don't understand it.
I don't understand how the
commissions let this slide.
I don't know how difficult it is to
fire these people would approve they're
incompetent.
But I do know that especially with with,
oh,
I guess it's probably true
with both boxing and MMA,
there are countless fans out there.
They would do a far better job,
countless,
countless people that have experienced
in fighting countless people that have a
deep appreciation and understanding
of what's actually going on inside the
fight.
And these people don't get those jobs.
And instead the same fools continue
to give piss poor decisions or corrupt
decisions.
I mean,
whoever that woman was,
you know,
there's even mention people's names,
but there's been some decisions.
There's been some horrific
with the Mayweather.
Uh,
you told him about the
Mayweather Canelo Ah,
yes.
The woman had had in a drawer.
Yes.
What?
I'm not going to,
I know a name,
but I'm not going to it
her name either because
she was also involved in,
uh,
another one was it?
Yeah,
she got Tony Brown,
I think.
Manny Pacquiao.
Yeah.
She was involved in a couple.
Yeah,
a couple.
At least to,
I think we're being,
we're being responsible.
Um,
why was she still there?
Right.
Seriously.
Why was she,
why was she still that?
Why?
Yeah,
why?
Why was she still there?
I mean,
we're not talking about
neurosurgeon said really,
right.
We're talking about a job.
There's a lot of people that could do it.
I'm not saying it's an easy job,
but I'm saying there's a
lot of people that are,
have a real understanding of boxing.
They would have done a way better job.
I mean,
somebody robs a bank.
They're not your bank
teller the next week.
Exactly.
Well,
at all the promoters today is golden boy.
The best.
I mean,
at least Oscar de la Hoya,
Bernard Hopkins,
they're legit world champion fighters.
They have a dis attached to,
they got one.
They got to strengthen and got a weakness.
Their weakness is they attached
really attached at the hip to one.
You know,
there are solar system,
so to speak,
has one son and I sign is called Canelo.
Canelo disappears tomorrow
and they're fucked.
Yeah,
they're not happy.
They got some problems.
But listen now Hayman's out there,
you know,
he,
he's PBC.
You know,
he came along,
um,
he just signed a deal from what I read.
Um,
I think I'm saying the numbers right
where Fox gave him $50 million for a four
year deal to put fights out there and
he's probably got the best stable of
fighters.
I mean,
he's a,
he's got what the guy hasn't been fine,
but to guy was I think
was one of the best guys.
Thurman.
Um,
but you know,
he's got who I really loved.
His guy's a beast.
My son loves him.
Ah,
Spence arose fans.
He's a beast.
I mean,
the guy,
I like him inside and out.
What do I mean by that?
I mean,
he truly believes that he
should fight all the best.
He truly believes he's the best.
He truly believes he's
going to get to you.
You know what I mean?
And any fights that way.
And he's a great guy.
He's a good guy.
So it's cool.
Yeah,
it makes it better.
Yeah.
He's fun.
Got a big smile.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's better.
You know,
Terrence Crawford is another one out.
And so,
I mean haven's got a lotta,
he's also got wilder
and heavyweight champ,
but one of the champs,
whatever that is.
But what a,
technically he's got a lot of problems,
but he's kind of one thing that's
not a problem and confidence.
But one other thing,
oh my goodness.
He's thought
instead of a hammer,
it's the right hand.
Oh my goodness.
He,
oh listen,
I am mother fucker knocks out everybody,
man.
He,
if he hits you a,
and the Ortiz fight was very interesting,
right?
He was her teeth today who is a bad
shape and still referee might have helped
him a little,
but he was in bad shape.
And uh,
but boy,
oh boy hill,
you know,
I say it a lot of times
he had that eraser,
you know,
I remember,
I remember I was not a great memory,
but as a kid,
somehow I wound up in a
Catholic school for a minute.
And those nuns,
they,
they should have been fighters.
They were mean.
I think they were a little twisted,
some of them.
But I'm not going to go to,
but they were little,
they would mean,
but they had no problem hitting you
in the head with that black racer.
Like you won't Pay Bang.
It was just like,
and it was hard.
It was like,
I don't,
that's fine.
You know.
And he has that eraser.
That's the point on.
He has done a razor where
bank put his technique,
his feet come up on the tone,
take the bear lands technique,
bed power,
good Sherlock log,
boom.
Really?
He lands.
People go flying.
I mean giant heavyweight
either in terms of his smell,
but you know what he is.
So he's long and he's tall
and he looked at those arms.
He was long.
I mean he could hear,
he could hit you across the room.
Well sows,
Tyson fury.
And that's one of the things
that makes this fight very,
very interesting.
That's one of the times where
that's saying styles make fights.
That's going up.
That's going to be this fight.
That's going to be the whole thing.
Tyson fury as a motherfucker.
Well,
he could move.
Yeah.
It's not only six,
seven or whatever the hell he is,
six,
eight,
nine long.
But he can move each had legs.
Phenomenal.
Yeah.
Somebody forgot to tell me he's a
heavy because he moves around like a
lightweight and that could
be a problem until he gets,
it also talks tremendous
shit until he gets it.
Well then,
then things change.
But I always used to say
when I was doing a broadcast,
so if I,
I would always say,
and I,
of course,
I wouldn't say it if I didn't
have a belief in us and,
and the proof of it,
in my mind at least that punches are
born then I made you're born when you're
not born to be a punch of that level.
And I'll tell you something funny that,
because you brought it up about him being,
you know,
he's not a big,
he's not that prototypical big Husky,
you know,
uh,
wedged out.
Yeah.
He's not that right.
But I'll tell you when
I was training fighters,
when I was young and I was taking them
to smokers in the Bronx to get experience
every week,
tough places in the South Bronx,
and we were taking them to these
unsanctioned fights just to get them
experience.
And if I didn't know the fight,
I say I had,
I'm responsible for these kids back then.
I'm like their parent and their trust me,
some of them didn't have parents,
but the ones that did,
they would trust me to
take care of this kid.
They didn't know what was
going to the South Bronx where,
where,
I remember one time,
uh,
I bought a car from somebody,
they didn't have to cook enough car.
It was the publisher of the newspaper,
the Catskill Daily Mail.
And,
and I've gone through his name of the
publisher and I bought his station wagon.
I didn't have a car big
enough to take the kids.
And um,
as I'm leaving,
he says,
it's,
you're not taking a real bad place
where they'd like rob hubcaps.
So something.
And I was like,
no,
because I didn't think I was lying
because to me they brought the whole car.
So,
so I said no because
he left it at hubcaps.
Right.
So I said no.
So I get there in the first thing I did,
I do is I pull the,
you know,
underneath the l you know for people
don't know is to train subway in the train
and I underneath and,
and uh,
that was,
you talk about life grown up quick.
You in one night it was like live reading
chapters of a book to you went through
different things and you learn different
things about yourself and about what's
there,
what you don't see a and
you haven't been around,
but it's there and it's good to know
it's there a different life to different
way.
And I'm down in the South Bronx and,
and our first thing I did,
I went to Mrs. Santos who was the father,
one of my kids.
I went to his ball,
cross the street,
said Mrs Central,
my cars over there.
Gotcha.
And why come out?
And all the batteries of the
cars were client except mine
quite often.
And uh,
but my car was good.
It's the Santos and his crew made
sure that nobody took my battery.
And so we were good.
So I was looking out for the kids
because I did what I had to do,
but it was a scary place.
It was a tough place.
And um,
the kids grew up fast.
It was three flights and it was often
thought that it was meant to be three
flights because she had time
to think during those flights.
The first flight,
quite frankly,
are you saw syringes,
sometimes kids didn't or non bad.
These kids will Catskill New York,
they really syringes
then.
Then the next flight,
you know,
you smelled urine because
people were there.
They went up there and they were,
you know,
going to bathroom,
doing whatever and shooting
up or whatever and you smell.
But then by the time
you get to dirt flight,
you've started to hear noise,
started to hear salsa music
and you,
uh,
you could smell some.
There were,
they were cooking all
the Spanish specialties,
the A to five bananas,
the uh,
the meat with the,
with the potato in the middle
plantaris and all that.
I remember,
you know,
I don't remember what the names,
but all the different inn,
of course,
a lot of Rome,
a lot of,
there was a bar,
but that's how they kept,
that's how they paid the rent for the
gym because they would do these smokers
twice a month.
You know,
there was a smoke every week in New York.
Every week.
People had to know where they were,
but they were every week.
And Leah,
they won't sanction.
There was no doctrine.
Listen,
I'm going out there and saying,
yeah,
that don't sound too good.
I got you.
But we made it good.
Yeah,
we made it good.
We made sure we took care of,
we've,
we've made it.
I know it was still dangerous.
It was stolen,
but you want to know something?
A kid drinking a bottle of vodka a
day was pretty freaking dangerous.
Okay.
I had some idiot one time.
I was trying to get money
from my foundation and I
was explaining to him and he
was a political guy and I was
explaining to him and he goes,
have you got brain damage and bugs?
And it's very day like I was trying to
like you when you want to throw your
headset when you see these trucks.
I was like trying to control,
I'm trying to talk to them.
I supposed to talk the right guy,
wait,
this guy who I'm going to
get money from my foundation,
it helps these people.
Right.
So I'm trying to talk
to him and I'm saying,
um,
do you get brain damage from being out
in the street and getting hit with a pipe
to get by deed because there's
the people I'm helping.
Do you get brain damage
arm from doing crack?
Do you get brain damage?
I did have a kid who drank a bottle
of vodka now when he gave to him to my
program and the foundation that we run,
uh,
for two years,
he's been announced three years,
he's been clean or his back was family.
He was living on the streets.
He was with gangs and when he got
into boxing in one of our programs,
uh,
he,
he stopped all that,
but he was drinking a
bottle of vodka years.
True.
15 year.
Yeah.
A lot of people say,
Teddy,
how do you drink?
Yeah,
but he was,
how do you do it?
Because you have a lot of
pain maybe or whatever,
whatever.
But yeah,
he was,
and so I was,
I said to the guy who was trying,
not to get into an argument,
but I was like,
boxing causes brain damage,
but I'm taking guys away.
Kids said the alternative is to
bottle of vodka to crack the needle,
the pipe on the head or maybe the pipe
on someone else's head where they caused
brain damage to someone else.
Maybe.
Unfortunately you'll one day
walking out of your house.
What about that brain damage?
That's your way of telling me know
that your way of not giving me what I'm
asking for to say that.
Why don't you think it
out a little bit more?
Why don't you think it out a little
more and give me a better excuse?
Why don't you at least
understand what we're doing.
Yeah.
There's a reason why we're doing this.
So these kids,
we would go,
we would go to the south
Bronx and these kids would,
they'd walk up,
like I said,
they've woke up to steps by
time that door opened up and,
and again this is how they paid
the rent by selling liquor,
by charging,
treat hours to get in
and selling that food.
And a place would be packed,
packed.
And when the l went by,
you talk about,
you told me,
we talked a little bit
about pressure and about,
you know,
what pressure does to you.
It can form,
you could destroy,
you could form,
you can make you realize
what you're capable of.
You know,
the greatest thing about what [inaudible]
and does for somebody who makes them
know,
Teddy,
what is box and do for you?
Oh those are your jabs.
You do know your condition,
you take care of your temple,
your body,
all that stuff.
Yeah,
it sounds good.
Teddy,
give us one thing that
box and does forever.
It lets you know you
could depend on yourself.
Lets a kid know that he can like himself.
We don't know.
He can like himself and depend on himself.
These kids.
So
was it rough?
He was rough.
So we're in a place and
there's is no doctor here.
We had no sanction and organization.
We made own fights,
but there was a danger.
But I just told you the other dangers,
this was taken them and replacing those
other dangers too is taking them away
from the,
you know what?
It was the only positive thing in
the neighborhood for these kids.
It really was,
was a rough,
yeah,
suboxone.
But I just talked about life is rough,
especially for these people refer.
So it was an alternative to violence.
People say,
Teddy,
what are you talking about?
Bhags no,
because if you're angry,
which these kids are,
if they don't learn to lose that anger,
they never become anything in boxing
because they walk in and get head.
They learned that they
can control that anger.
They could put it somewhere.
They learned that they
can control themselves.
They can depend on themselves
to be something positive.
So I would take these kids and we would
go there and we were the only white kids
in the place.
And they loved us.
They were funny.
Like I said,
the guy who ran it,
Nelson quavers,
he would,
he's a great guy,
but he,
you know,
I would look,
he carried a gun in his holster and
it's in his belt felt because he knew it
could be rough.
I mean,
I did,
I leave that part out to the parents
when I was taking him that the proprietor
of the place,
you know,
has a gun and every once in
a while he opens his jacket,
make sure that the people
remember that he has.
Yeah.
Alright.
But they looked out for you.
They,
the kids.
I know,
I know it sounds contrary.
I get it contradictory,
but it was a,
these kids,
they learned so much about
themselves and we protect,
I looked at,
we'd looked out for,
and when it came time to
make the matches to point,
I was making about Walden.
And you talked about
being long and about you.
I'm sorry I jump all over the place.
But uh,
I,
oh,
I learned,
cause taught me this.
But you have to learn it yourself.
You have to see it.
You have to be in it
because told me about it.
But that's only part of it.
He always told me,
teddy,
be careful with skinny wirey guys.
They had the greatest punches.
Think I was thinking,
you know this,
they're the greatest punches.
He never told me why he
let me figure it out.
I saw it.
I saw when he get him out.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Hearns here,
but I know why now leverage.
Yeah,
talk,
whatever you call that.
And so anyway,
so here we are.
And if you saw the guy you
knew who to match with,
but if you didn't see the guy,
you had to depend on other things.
Who's the coach?
Certain coaches had no good fighters.
Certain coaches,
they're good fighters.
Another coach.
Does he have a good
realize he honest sea lion.
Does he have,
does he have an opinion that is
good or does he just say things?
So I'd have to go to all that
if I didn't know the guy,
I wouldn't put my kid in with the
guy unless I was sure what he was.
Sure.
And it was hard because
everyone was lying though.
There was like a cold.
It was all connected
to lion unfortunately.
But,
but everyone looking out for their kid,
like if you'd said it,
I'll give you an example because
we guess who the matchmaker was.
I became the matchmaker with,
you know,
in a place where all Spanish black,
white,
but Nelson made me the matchmaker.
You be the matchmaker and a lot of
the people didn't speak English.
So you know,
we've,
we figured out we get there.
So I'd be the,
so you make a column,
the name of the fighter.
The weight.
Yeah.
He saw you your way him,
you know,
that's one thing.
You see it.
Okay.
That's the only truth.
The rest of it got dicey.
Okay.
How many fights most important thing?
Most important thing.
How many fights?
Zero.
Everyone in this place got zero fights
and Al Said nobody got
fights in its place.
Even doing this for years.
It's all okay,
here's the code.
Zero fights means two or three.
One,
two or three fights meant six to 10
God forbid anyone ever said they had five,
six fights,
anywhere from 25 to a hundred
real,
real.
This is the world that
I lived in for five,
six years.
Took them every Friday,
every drove down to the Bronx
and got them a smoker every week.
And so you figured out
to code after awhile,
but you're responsible for these kids
who you wanted every tangible thing you
could have.
So again,
if I wasn't sure how much the guy was
lying that he was lying a little extra,
I would,
I'd go to Nelson.
You know this guy?
No,
but talk to Pablo.
Talk down.
Hell,
all right.
You know the guy?
No.
Yeah,
he's stay away from no fight.
You know,
because I'm not taking the chair.
But then when you get to the
point where you don't really know,
then I would just,
your instincts come alive.
You're protecting your kid.
It's your kid,
it's your kid.
As much as it's paternally your kid,
I remember one time I went up to the guy,
I couldn't get enough info.
I went up to the guy
bought Nelson as an interpreter because
he didn't speak English and I said
I know what we do here.
Well I'm telling you is I'm not
putting my kid in to get beat up.
If it's fair,
it's fair by not putting them in
with a kid that's got 30 40 fights.
My kid legitimate
legitimately has two fights.
I'm telling you,
I know we don't do that here.
I'm telling you that's what he's got.
If your kid's got 40 foot,
tell me,
just tell me and say no fight and,
and I'll shake your hand and that's it.
We're good.
So he kept,
he stood to his story.
Okay,
so we get close in.
Now I'm thinking,
I'm thinking,
I'm thinking and I'm watching a
guy warmup cause always told me,
watch the Guy Walmart,
watch them warm up.
I want you to more more pop pop pop by
bap.
Bap,
I said this guy didn't have to fight.
I mean,
I'm a pretty good trainer
and even with our fights,
I think I teach them technically what
they need to know before they get to
explore.
But this guy was beyond that.
I mean,
you know this was sugar ray Robinson.
So I go back to Nelson.
I said,
bring him over here again
10 minutes before the fight.
So bring them over here again.
Comes on,
or a little bit of an attitude so bad.
Everyone's got attitudes in this business.
Is it?
Hey
listen
one more time.
I just want to tell you
not threatening you,
but I have to tell you this.
It told me he's got no fights,
whatever,
to five,
whatever.
When the bell rings,
if you got over on me,
I was wrong.
You were right.
Soon as the bell rings,
I'm going to see,
I'm going to know it.
There's not new can say
afterwards to say to explain it,
handle it,
and I'll stop to fight if I have
to because I'll protect my kid.
I might have to.
I do that.
I'll be coming over to you.
That's all I'm going to say.
Okay.
So please,
please for you.
For me,
please.
If it's,
if it's,
if it's what I'm saying,
please just,
just tell him,
Nelson,
you don't have to tell me.
Just tell Nelsa when I leave here
that we're not going to fight.
Nelson came back to me four minutes,
three minutes,
two minutes later and said,
he said no fight.
Thank you.
Tell him thank you.
That's the world we lived in there,
but we got it done.
We got it done though,
Joe.
We did.
We really did.
And thank God that someone like you was
able to understand that there is a big
difference and that you can,
you know,
these guys that sandbag like that,
that's very,
very common and,
and yeah,
and see they think that they're gaining
something because you know what I mean?
It's just want to fuck somebody.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so,
but let me tell you something.
My kids,
I mean like when,
when we first started fighting,
they had bungled Trumpsters hi.
I,
I mean my kids had never seen bound.
I didn't see Bongo drums.
That,
what am I saying?
But they were this high,
they were bundle and
they were in the ring.
They only came out when,
when we,
when we got ready to fight and the
playing of bangles and you know,
great music.
I mean really it was,
you know,
but you know what,
when you're hearing that bungle music
and you're in the ring and you're talking
to the kid in the corner and they're
outside now with the bangles and they're
playing the bongos and you're talking,
that's an atmosphere.
Yeah.
That's different.
That's real experience.
That's experience.
That's life experience.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's not taught in the classroom.
And,
and my kids have to six years of that
because that's about how long we did know
I was up to seven years
train of photos for cost.
So,
um,
I'm telling you,
my kids grew up,
they go to,
they will go on to be pros and did
they go on to be Olympic chair now?
But they took that and they used it
to be better at what they did into,
to have the confidence to do things they
might not have had the confidence to do
without that experience.
I got a couple of them
that have state troopers.
I got a couple of them that
are teachers in high school.
I got to cook,
you know,
all different things.
Who coupled of one per college that,
that the nobody in their,
in their history of their family
ever went beyond high school and,
but they went to college and
they were kind of told them,
you're never going to go to college.
They went to college and I,
I would like to believe it
had something to do with that,
you know,
and um,
I lot of people ask me,
you,
whom was you greatly because
I had Tyson to there,
you know,
he was,
he became one of them.
And um,
I remember it was funny because
when I would put it down,
like I said,
everyone lied about the experience,
but you know,
they lied about everything.
But I would put down,
uh,
you know,
the,
the age and everything else,
all the stuff for what it was worth,
you had to have something
to try to believe in if I
didn't have to figure it out
from there.
So Tyson,
when I first had him,
he was 190 pounds,
not a bum.
Also 12 years old.
Okay.
That's what it was.
But that's what he was,
I mean,
that's what God made it.
So,
so I go down and I put the first fight.
Nobody seen Tyson.
Nobody's ever seen data,
but 12 years old or zero phase.
Okay.
Hello
Daddy.
Now you go too far.
You like more than us.
Huh?
You don't know.
You learn a lot from us.
Okay.
Is it,
cause that's a compliment.
I said,
I think for the Nelson,
that's a compliment.
I mean,
I'd take a day because it is right,
right.
I'm not lying.
12 years old,
190 pounds.
Please,
please,
please.
Now.
So I'm not learning.
Okay.
He's 12 years old.
It's going to be 13 soon,
but he's technically,
he's 12 years old.
Okay.
Oh,
come on.
I said,
all right,
I'll make you feel bad.
I put down 17 thank you.
Now you tell the truth.
Jay's not 17,
but I knew what I have.
I know.
Like I said,
I knew what I had.
So I bought a 17 year old.
I wasn't going to fight.
No 12 year old that was going to happen.
Right.
And plus I get arrested for murder.
So,
oh,
what was he like at 12 years old?
Physically,
mentally weak.
But physically,
what do I mean mentally weak,
not weak for the average guy,
but before fighter,
um,
he's still have remanence
he still had residual
stuff from his upbringing.
Listen,
you want to know the truth about the guy?
I mean,
you,
he oldest,
but he used to hide in between
abandoned building walls in Brownsville.
It was a rough place,
no doubt about it.
Did have a fall or whatever,
the model of whatever.
And uh,
he,
he used to hide between
walls to not get picked on.
And I believe when you do that,
you never get outside of that
wall to a certain extent.
You're always hiding in a wall for the
rest of your life as this is my belief
that teddy,
what are you talking about?
It became heavyweight champ.
Some people think he's the greatest.
I'll bet.
No,
I don't have his record in front of me
and this is going to blow some people
crazy,
but what are you going to do?
I don't have his record.
Let's just say we're going to make an
arbitrary number because your man's going
to pull it up,
but let's just say it's
50 and six all right,
we'll we'll say five 15 five but whatever.
I think his record
is truly,
if you're going to be this,
and we're not truly in life with anything,
but if we're truly,
truly in an Absolut world,
which we don't live in,
but I would say he's all in five high now.
Everybody says,
everyone who's listening
to you think is just like,
let me get with Teddy's drinking,
like I don't see them drinking nothing,
but he probably had
some before he came in.
To me,
a fight is not a fight into
this resistance to there's
something to overcome,
something to overcome.
Otherwise,
it's just an athletic venture.
It's an exhibition.
I think life is that,
I think the,
you don't know of a lawyer is
a lawyer and to into the some,
the overcoming the courtroom.
Something goes for,
okay.
I know he's a lawyer.
I know.
He went to see,
I get it.
Nobody has to tell me that,
but he ain't a lawyer.
He Ain't dad until everything goes wrong.
The judge throws all this crap out and,
and he's,
he is aft,
so to speak and,
and he figures and he's still handles it.
Then he's a lawyer.
A doctor is not a doctor.
And two,
he opens up this kid,
a kid just like he's got it home and
arteries are bleeding all over the place
and,
and it,
it's not in a textbook.
It's not in a brick and textbook.
And he got to do it.
He got to figure it out and he got,
then he's a doctor that he's
a surgeon at that level.
You're not,
you are not in a fight.
I,
look,
I admitted.
I equate life to a fight.
I do.
You're not in a fight.
And so there's pressure
resistance overcoming something.
Otherwise it shows an exhibition.
Tyson's talent was so great,
his physical ability,
his talent was so overwhelming,
just like somebody
intellect to some bodies,
charisma,
whatever beauty until it
came to something else.
But his talent was so superior that
the other stuff never got tested.
He was blown guys out and
he had never got tested.
If there was anything in the warehouse,
so to speak of is anything
inside you never knew.
And then five times,
whatever the real record is,
five times there was resistance.
Five times it became a real fight.
Five Times.
There was something to overcome and he
fell in all five times who only in five
fights in his life.
And he's all in five.
I'm sorry sal graves,
because we know my history with them.
Right.
Am I,
am I,
am I capable of died?
Yam Newman.
Yeah.
But I can honestly tell you,
okay,
that I,
I took,
um,
I try to be better than that,
that,
that I've called many fights
where the people in corner,
I couldn't stand him.
I had no respect for them.
But if they,
if they did a good job
in a corner to fight,
it did a job.
I talked to bat like they were Ray Arcel
like they were Angelo Dundee because
that's what it was supposed to be.
That's all.
And it's selfish because
I told want I wanna have,
I wanna know and I want my kids to
know that I can be better than that.
That,
that it's,
it's about right.
Okay.
It's about the code of,
of the profession.
It's a,
it's about you.
It's about,
you believe in that.
Would you say is
she'll be honest.
It should be what you believe.
It shouldn't be tainted or,
or,
or influenced by lesser things that,
that it does represent you.
Does represent your family.
It does represent where you came from.
It does stay.
Do you know your blurted out for those
five minutes or maybe two hours on ESPN,
but it stays somewhat can go back to it.
You could go back to it.
How do you feel about it?
It does mean,
so it really does it.
And so I'm only saying it because
I would say it about somebody else.
In a way that I calibrate things,
the way that I evaluate things that I
don't think that you know crap about
somebody until they're tested.
You don't know the friend.
You don't know if they're good wife.
You don't know if the good girlfriend,
you don't know crap you think you do,
but until they really tested,
you don't really know.
And Tyson,
when he got tested,
when he had to overcome some,
when when he didn't run him over,
like,
like one of those big monster trucks
running over a Volkswagen because he was a
monster truck for Volkswagens.
Yeah,
he was.
And was he wanted the
greatest punches or don't?
Yeah.
Yes.
Could he punched from either side of the
plate like Mickey Mann or the greatest
switch hitter?
Was He that in by,
yes.
Could he could punch evenly.
Great with either hand from either side.
Was he all those things?
Yes.
Was he as great intimidators Sonny Liston?
Was he a great finisher like Joe Louis?
To a certain extent,
yes.
But it wasn't a great fighter
because great fighters won.
The fight came to them.
They found a way to do
what they had to do.
He found a way to disappear.
They found a way to show up.
Yeah,
show up.
He found the way to go
and not show up and look.
You could go talk to psychiatrists and
you could go to all the reasons why.
Hiding between a war when he was a kid.
Yeah,
that's part of it.
I'll tell you another part of it.
To be that,
not to be the power puncher,
not to be the aggressor,
not to be.
Just those things.
To be the Titan,
to be the Viking,
to be the Samurai,
to be the warrior,
to be those things has to be inside you.
You have to believe it.
It all.
A lot of times people will lie in life.
This is Fullerton plays.
You can't lie.
Okay.
You know,
sometimes we'd say that the
ring is the Chamber of truth.
You know,
it sounds good and all that,
but it is.
It is because just like
in other places in life,
so when moment comes
for those kinds of serious things,
you have to feel like that.
You say that you're the conqueror,
you Alexander the great you,
all those things,
right.
Okay.
Words sounds great.
Makes good soundbites.
Probably bring more people to the TV,
but when the moment comes and you didn't
intimidate a guy that didn't work.
Okay.
We all try it to a certain extent,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
I'm sure you've looked at guys certain
ways when you were younger and and you'd
purposely looked at them in
a way to invoke a certain
kind of action,
a certain kind of result,
fund them.
Just,
just look at Adam and a real serious
way that you hope that it weakened them.
Yeah.
And but because I know your background,
you were prepared to do
what came after that,
but some people aren't.
Some people aren't.
And Tyson was in
as great as he was.
I just said it.
He's great guys that
hate me for this today,
your hero or whatever,
your favorite guy,
when he's great,
just not great.
And in his area and
when that moment comes,
you have to,
that's where the truth matters.
You have to believe that you really,
that guy.
And if your guide that
he listened,
he was convicted.
So I think it's fair that rape somebody.
Okay,
now listen,
I wasn't in an AV Rome and I don't know,
a lot of people don't take
okay but he was convicted or,
but I know enough people in the business
that there was a lot of other bad
things that he did that are
just not things that that
you would probably want to
hang around with somebody if you know,
if you're a halfway decent human
being that he did devil week things.
Okay.
Week.
Thanks.
So when you do read things and you know
you did though and I don't know what,
but I'm just saying you do week things
and you know they will week things and
now you got to do a strong thing.
How do you become strong when you know
that you did those weak things and you
know that's really you and you got a guy,
a course way from your name,
Nevada Holyfield that doesn't give
a shit about how hard you punch.
Does it give a crap about
what a finisher yard does?
It give a crap about how fair is
you put your punches together.
He wants to find,
you're going to have to make him a
believer by doing it and doing it in a
difficult place because he's gonna make
it difficult because he ain't got to
cooperate.
When that happens,
you got to feel like that person.
And when you don't feel like that person,
you got a problem.
And as what happened wasn't
a matter when he bit his ear,
it was a matter that he was hungry and
he was a savage and he was from the
should stop the crap.
It was a way to get out
cause he knew he wasn't that guy.
And when you're not,
that guy goes,
what do you have a great talent off?
Recognize when somebody is
there as your greatest talent,
he can recognize when somebody is,
and he recognized that Evander Holyfield
was and I was his way to get out
and he did.
So that's why again,
it's not sour grapes.
It's really not because
I'm more selfish than that.
I really do care about
what well my reputation
is and whether or not,
uh,
I've been honest about things.
I say,
it doesn't mean I'm right per means.
I believe it.
I do care about that.
I do.
And so it's not that it
doesn't mean I'm right,
but it means I have a reason to
believe on right from the way of live,
from what I've seen,
what I've experienced in the business,
the human condition,
how strong it can be
and how we could can be.
And um,
he was a stronger guys.
Are you ever going to see,
but he was his week of person
as you ever going to find.
That's intense.
But I see what you're saying in terms
of you are judging it by the highest
standards possible.
You're judging it in
comparison to other champions.
You're judging it.
You,
you,
what else you got to
jump through with Joe,
of course.
Well,
you look at guys who are known for
incredible heart and their ability to come
back like Diego corrals,
David Carlson,
some of those wars when
you would say could steal.
Yes.
That was one of the
greatest fights of all time.
The forest of credible,
greatest fight of all Micky ward.
Arturo.
Gary,
the first one,
right?
Not the second door.
The first,
the first.
Unbelievable.
I mean,
no,
if you want to go back,
if you want to go back farther,
most a lot of people will know this,
but you should call him was involved
in a lot and unfortunately he paid the
price.
Okay.
Yes.
But Bobby should call in in the 70s,
eighties.
He was involved in those
fights every other day.
You know,
I'm just kidding.
But he was invited to
many of those fights.
Yeah.
And unfortunately you don't know about
Bobby should call and you talk to
somebody again,
like the baseball thing,
you talk about the average guy,
Bobby Chicago and who the hell's that?
Who the hell is that affords is a
guy that would know his name anymore.
But uh,
he was a pretty special
guy and everything.
He was pretty damn tough.
Tougher than most people.
There's guys that unfortunately
relied on that toughness.
Right?
Yeah.
Like when you,
when it comes to guys
known for incredible Chins,
that can be a detriment.
Yes.
And it can be if that's all you have.
Do you think that's what you have?
Cause she used to put it this way cause
she used to that because he wanted me to
a great trainer.
So cause she used to always be with me.
All the tools,
you know,
scientists and cuss would say day
got two tough guys.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Now
well it's tough.
It's a prerequisite to be in a fighter.
You better be tough.
But one level.
So all levels the greys and I got you.
But how special is being tough?
Because if you're a fighter
you should be tough.
I gotcha.
Homelessness.
So you've got two tough guys,
but one of them is smart.
Taught,
developed.
That's him.
He's tough one now.
That's how he explained it.
Tougher because he's smart.
Yeah.
Tough and smart.
He,
he goes from here,
he's here because he's not just
dependent only on toughness.
So He's tougher than this guy.
Right.
Cause he don't have to
depend on just that.
You might not even have to get to it.
It's there as a reserve.
It's always there to call on like an army.
You call on,
you need it.
Right.
But he's not dependent just on that.
Isn't that the balance though,
is knowing that you have it.
Yeah.
Knowing that you have it.
There it is.
See what you just said.
You have to know that are it.
Tyson didn't know he was it.
We ever admit that.
He probably knocked me and say dessert,
whatever.
I don't,
it's okay.
And so I get I,
Well there's certain people that you
can't question and Aranda Holyfield's one
of those people.
That's why that fight was so
fascinating because it was Phil was,
he is a 100% warrior.
Well he had to write nickname.
Most of them don't.
Most of them don't have to write
fight nickname and whatever they do.
Right.
But the real,
the real deal,
he was the real deal.
Yeah.
And why small heavyweights?
You want to know why?
I mean trace it back,
cause always told me this,
but I learned it innately on my own too.
But trace it back to the parents,
trace it back to the background traitor,
trace it back to all that stuff,
trace it back.
He did.
He didn't live up to something.
He didn't face something.
He didn't do.
Whatever it was there was about,
he had a mother that he talked
about a few times and I,
I'm sorry,
event of,
I'm not saying exact but,
but it's,
it's there
that and a great model obviously,
but she,
they had a,
the crop and Georgia tech,
it was Atlanta pub,
whatever suburb of Georgia
and she,
you have definite age and on different
time down south and all that,
had a little,
I guess a little shack in the back
with a thing called twitches switch.
It switches.
I'm sorry,
I'm twitching
switches.
And
she basically had different size switches,
you know,
short ones,
long ones,
medium ones depending on the occasion.
And when he didn't live up to
what he had to tell the truth,
whatever,
be accountable.
Okay.
Face what he had to face,
whatever.
Um,
she had a switch for
him and you know what,
it um,
informed him because he faced things.
Tyson Tyson on the other hand and listen,
did he asked for it?
No,
no,
he didn't ask for that.
Oh brilliant.
I get it.
But I know people have that upbringing
and they get to a point they can,
they can make a left turn instead.
All right.
Turn is your ability to make,
I think there was also the,
the overwhelming hype and celebrity
involved in Mike Tyson in his prime,
it was probably so difficult for
him to even understand himself.
Yeah.
But,
but what he did understand,
and I'm glad you said that
right backwards,
what he did and what he did understand
it was there was a way out of van learn,
there was no way out,
you know,
oppose away,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Yeah.
Like somebody would come and pay.
And he did a lot of things before he
became champion and somebody was always
there with a check or cash or whatever.
And,
and w would absolve them from,
it would,
would not have to face what he did.
Right.
And,
and,
but there was a switch that a van,
the hat of face and that's what made him,
what made him,
and that's what allowed
Tyson part of would move out.
Tyson,
you look,
you make your own choice
at a certain point life.
So there's not make too many excuses,
but it is part of it that,
that he was formed by what he was
allowed to do when he shouldn't have been
allowed to do those things.
So that was one of the issues
that you had with costs,
right?
Yeah.
That you felt like costs was ignoring
his own principles and teaching because
this guy was so special.
Yeah.
And cause was getting older
and cost recognize you
didn't have much time left in
this guy had a legitimate shot at being
a world champion and for cause heavy
thing in his June.
Everything in the world of
boxing success and everything.
He was great.
He was special because his whole life he
didn't get married for a reason because
he was married to box.
And as he said that it wouldn't been fair.
I mean,
this was a different guy that
it was boxing his whole lot,
everything.
Life was boxing and lessons
were connected to boxing,
everything and um,
principals boxing.
And uh,
so there's,
uh,
you know,
there's a guy that his whole,
you use that word legacy,
but really his whole existence was boxing.
And for him it was heavyweight champion.
He had Floyd Patterson,
youngest heavyweight champ ever.
That was cost.
It was about lightweights.
Lizard.
He had lightweights.
He had welterweights,
Jose Torres,
Jose toys,
light heavyweight champion.
Exactly right.
He had other guys too.
But it was the heavyweight champion of
the world because it was around where we
talked about before when
box was the biggest sport,
bigger than baseball.
And it was the heavyweight champ of
the world was Babe Ruth [inaudible],
Seattle and that,
and you're going to say that
before you leave this earth,
that you have a chance to have another
heavyweight champ that might be the best,
could be one of the best ever and
could break Patterson's record,
which was part of the plan,
part of the plan when costs was alive.
You're going to break Patterson's reg.
He broke it.
He became the youngest
heavyweight champion.
And so when you float that out there,
if you will,
and tempt the guy with that,
even a great guy like costs,
some things are going to
be a push to the side.
And Ethan,
yeah,
compromised.
And he did.
Do you think if he didn't do that the
Tyson would have been a different person?
I'm going to use his words that
was told to me by a great promoter.
Mickey toppy passed away.
It was close to Jim Jacobs who was close
to cause and he was up there sometimes
after I left and all that.
And Mickey wanted me to train all his
fighters and he was a great promoter.
Mickey,
he had great sayings.
He was a very witty guy,
but he was a sharp guy.
Boxing was his life too.
And he ran everything in
London with three partners.
One of them was Java sustain
who owned Wembley Stadium.
So they were powerful.
They ran everything.
They were the cartel in
London back in those days.
He told me that before Carlos died that
cause had said some nice things about
teddy atlas,
but he said,
and La's,
I know there's a danger
that this can be convenient.
You know what I mean?
Self serving crap.
Sometimes you got to trust whatever.
I was told by Mickey that he said that
yeah,
Teddy Atlas was right by the way,
was wrong was who's going to get in a
way of the possibility of making a great
fighter.
Okay.
Um,
if he did things his way as far as the
disciplining in the in or whatever,
um,
eve,
in other words,
whether he left it like that,
so I don't know.
So I know what I think it meant that
Thaisa wouldn't have been around if you
did,
if you discipline that
he would have laughed.
I don't know,
cause I don't know that he had those
options because he was a ward of the state
and,
uh,
you know,
it was coming out of obviously a
criminal situation who's coming out of a
juvenile detention center
called Trion up outside of old,
30 miles outside Albany.
Um,
you know,
so I don't know that he had,
but basically that if
teddy did it his way,
he was right.
But he was wrong because it would have
ruined the possibility of a great fighter
and I couldn't let that happen.
So I don't think that it's,
I dunno if it's true,
actually.
I don't know.
You know what I was about to say?
I don't think that's true
because of course it's me,
right?
I want to make myself feel good.
So I want to say you could
have the best of both worlds.
So good.
We had maybe a better person or
within the realm of a better person,
right?
Boundaries,
right.
There were no boundaries.
Maybe there would have those boundaries
would have made a difference.
Right.
And you still would have had the talent.
He was so absent.
The talent wasn't going to dissipate
because I have to discipline,
you know,
that you put on them as a human being.
That wasn't going to change.
But because,
because we're saying that,
uh,
it wasn't going to happen.
Maybe you'll lose them.
Maybe it goes to someone else at a
certain point in his development.
Maybe that's what he meant.
I don't know what you had
that with Shannon kitchen.
Shannon Briggs.
Yeah.
Shannon brings,
came from Brownsville and he was,
I had him as a young,
you know,
developing program.
We got to a certain point.
But you also had that situation with him
where you felt like he wasn't 100% in,
he wasn't doing the things
you wanted him to do.
He was,
he was lacking in a certain amount of
discipline or he was distracted in a
certain amount of ways that bothered you
to the point where you didn't want to
work with them anymore.
It wasn't committed,
I didn't think completely.
But,
uh,
he was a smart kid.
Take your kid.
Talented,
talented,
very talented,
smart,
you know,
he knew how to market himself.
He had to dreadlocks and he
made them orange and you know,
nobody was doing that back then and he
could punch it was talented and he looked
good,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
but it's real commitment.
I didn't think because then,
and maybe in the two to his credit,
he had others,
he was smart and he
thought of other things,
but
he never really bought in.
That is the end all was boxing that,
that,
that was the complete,
I don't want to use just as average,
same standard word.
Commitment,
right?
Like what the figures that
sometimes like commitment,
but
more than commitment.
He said all the right things because
they had investors and they had different
people.
It's their bad thing.
Everyone does.
They,
if you're talented enough,
you draw those kinds of things.
To his credit,
he deserved it.
He,
he did something to bring
investors and people to back them,
but he got so used to saying
what they needed to hear
that he never knew what he needed to hear.
He never,
he and what he needed to hear and
believe was that I'm really going to do
it.
He got so good at selling it that
he never got good at buying it.
He,
he never really,
he just thought that I
ride this train and to
hm.
I write is trained to,
I fall off or toe comes off the
track or to comes to a stop,
but it is going to come to a stop.
And I'm not saying everyone
can have that confidence.
Everyone can have that belief.
I'm not saying that,
but you have to get it somewhere.
Sometime he didn't believe that
the train was really going on here.
He believed that it was just going to
go to a place where it was going to be
better than where he was and
that that he'll ride it as long,
but he,
he's not committed to staying on it.
When,
when,
uh,
when it turns come up and,
and it gets a little fast,
he doesn't believe that he's
really going to get there.
He believes that we're not first turn,
second turn,
third turn,
whatever on a rails coms
that that's going to be it,
but it's going to be,
it took a better place than he
was at it earned him some money.
It got him some things and,
and it was good,
but he never really,
there's that word committed,
but he never really believed.
And a lot of people don't.
They find their way along the way,
but he never believed that what he told
to people around them that he was going
to be,
he never believed that his
personality was too good.
His personality was too sharp.
He,
he,
he could say all the right things and
became easier to say the right things tend
to believe the right thing.
Does that make sense?
It does make sense.
This uncompromising psychology of combat
sports is uncompromising philosophy.
Is this something that you got from
costs as is something that you inherently
understood from working closely with these
guys and taking them to these smokers
in the South Bronx?
Where does this come from?
Just raw honesty.
Seen it all.
Listen,
the calm,
the form,
again,
you don't want to be Corny,
but it comes from living a certain way.
Life was seeing things traveling
to thing as part of it definitely,
but the,
the articulation of it,
the blueprint or map of it,
the seeing of it,
the visualization of it
on paper comes from costs.
He was a genius.
He was devastated world.
The,
the theory of it,
that's the better way.
The theory of it comes
from costs to living.
The doing of it comes from my father.
I had a father that most parks
and people don't come from,
although polarity,
great Mexican fighter,
but he came from something
like Davis who's,
he wanted to be a lawyer actually.
But anyway,
and you'd think Mexico,
you'd think why he came from the,
you know,
the,
the dirt floors and stuff,
which a lot of guys
come from and you know,
they pull themselves out
and that's part of the,
obviously the motivation.
But
my father was a doctor,
it was a GP practice,
55 years stand out in New York
again from the Bronx Santa.
He found the two hospitals.
He built a house for 22 beds in,
it was called sunny side some,
I don't know if that stuff even
existed in Google back then,
but anyway,
with Sunnyside hospital
and he built it so that
all people,
I listen,
whether he builds a,
so poor people,
he was,
he grew up very poor.
He,
he just,
he was an that kind of allow his,
because he just,
he built his hospital so that the less
of people with less could get hospital
care because back in those
days there were no h or moles.
There was no Obamacare.
There was no,
you know,
whether you think it's good,
it's bad,
it's there,
it doesn't matter.
There was nothing.
He wound up in a clinic.
Maybe you got all,
unless she had a doctor that
took care of me and he was,
and who are the doctors?
He wasn't the only one,
but he was the only one I knew.
And he founded Sunnyside hospital for
22 beds in her last about 25 years until
the Verrazano Bridge was built.
The city put the highway in there.
It changed,
sat down,
obviously fit,
connected pro-Clinton stand out and
you didn't have to take a ferry boat.
And He,
um,
the city border farmer and then he went
and found a doctor's hospital with 60
other doctors.
But he was the original founder,
him and a guy named doctor Tim Pawn Sr.
He founded doctors,
which was a big hospital.
Like I said,
30 years,
there was a big hospital,
but so he was a guy that he didn't waste
time telling me how to live and how all
that stuff.
The only thing I remember
was you say some do.
It
was,
I mean,
and then I watched him as a kid.
He was my hero.
I mean I liked Mickey Mann.
Oh.
And I liked Joe is,
you know,
all those things and
it's like any other kid.
But if I had a hero,
I didn't know what a hero was.
Am I going to make believe I knew,
but I know now what it's supposed to mean.
Right.
So he was my hero and I just,
I watched him,
you know,
when I went in his room one time,
when he graduated Nyu,
they didn't have money,
so he had to get scholarship.
He had to get help from different teams,
whatever they had to do.
But he got,
he went to Nyu medical school,
Nyu Undergrad,
and then he interned at Bellevue,
which that's,
he wasn't a big talker,
but he told me,
he did tell me when
you graduated Bellevue,
you ready for anything?
So of later in my life,
I took that as the South Bronx.
You graduated to South
Bronx to smoke smokers.
You were very funny thing.
You learned that you're
ready for anything.
You learn how to match,
make you ready.
You'll learn how to be a trainee
that you're ready fairy thing.
So he,
you know,
he,
he came,
I did knock on his door when he was,
what it was in turning
of Bellevue of young guy.
You know,
apparently he saved some obese woman's
life that had a heart attack in a street.
He dragged,
dragged her off the street,
whatever,
the,
you never get the whole story,
but he saved a life and
he developed a hernia at a
grown to a double hernia.
And my father was the kind of guy,
he didn't let anything
interfere with his patients,
his work,
he didn't take time to get it.
So he carried it for 30
years and he finally got it,
you know,
and so it become a double hernia.
I know hernia is now,
they do the Mesh and
they two ladies in there.
But in those days it was
a more serious thing.
He was evasive surgery.
Um,
it was different.
It was,
and it was painful apparently.
And,
uh,
I did knock on a door as a young kid,
you know,
very young,
but I still remember,
and there was a mirror here and he was
over there near his bed when the mirror
was here.
So I opened the door and in the
huck should have knocked obviously.
And um,
I saw he was bent over in pain.
I mean,
I could recognize and he
was wearing the thing.
I had no idea.
It was like,
I know what the figures that,
but it was probably not as,
you probably need you again to
give me the proper pronounciation.
Thank you for,
but it was trust.
I think it was rights suck as gutsy.
Yeah.
It was leather.
It was do things like this and you know,
I was like,
I don't know what the figures that,
you know,
I could,
but I could see he was in pain and
he had this thing on and he got mad,
told me to get out.
And,
um,
for the rest of my young life,
I knew there was some Raul,
I knew he was in pain every
day and he never showed it.
He never uses juice.
He worked every day,
including Sunday,
has office hours,
word joke because of
it's said on the thing,
you know,
four 30,
he stayed till nine 30 because he didn't
leave till the last patient left and
most of them Warren panel.
Okay.
You know,
he,
he took the patients that
other doctors didn't take,
took all the Medicare,
Medicaid,
whatever it was,
whatever the right one
is basically welfare.
He took all of them and you know,
he made the,
he had the biggest practice on Stan arm,
maybe the biggest in New York.
So all the,
all the,
all the drug salesman,
they,
they all migrated to his place.
You want to get his account Dot
Dallas to sell the new stuff,
to sell the drugs,
to sell the pills.
And he used them.
He didn't hide it,
but he made them,
he made them give them
huge amount of samples.
You know why?
Because his patients couldn't
afford to fill the prescriptions.
So we would give him the free samples.
I used to always wonder
what the freak all,
he said,
I know how to open up a closet.
There was like things falling on you,
you know,
like pills and stuff as
like what is hot and,
but it was so he could give it to them.
So they didn't have to fill a
prescription because they didn't.
There was,
again,
there was none of those things that
pay for your prescriptions that they do
today.
And they couldn't afford it.
They couldn't afford to go to him,
but he charged them $3,
$5,
whatever,
whatever it was that they could afford.
Yeah.
And you know,
he made money.
I mean,
he was a doctor,
but he didn't make the money
that other doctors will make it.
But he was a real,
docked a right for me at least.
And,
but more importantly,
he didn't talk about it.
He did it.
And he,
every day he was in pain.
Later on,
oh,
I was a little older,
but I was still young teenager.
I saw him put a white
pill onto his tongue.
I didn't know what the freak that was.
I later on I found out it was
nitrile that has hardwoods,
puts skipped beats,
but he still didn't say a word.
Didn't talk about it in all.
If he didn't have his son
who thought it was his hero,
he,
I wouldn't have known because
I looked at everything he did
and you know,
he um,
he did house calls.
Yeah,
he did.
House caused,
who is 80 years old,
charging $5,
whatever.
Nothing.
He had patients that could
not get to an emergency role.
They didn't have the ability to get there.
They didn't have a car.
They wouldn't shape
where they couldn't get,
they couldn't take a bus,
whatever.
But so he did house calls
and a patients when he died,
they all said,
hey Lou,
you sometimes you have to
wait till one in the morning.
But he got there.
That was the thing.
He always got there.
He always delivered.
And with all those things that I knew was,
you know,
his,
his kid.
Yeah.
He never used it.
Made an excuse.
And he was a fighter,
you know,
in,
in their own way.
He was to,
you know,
he was the best fighter of his
soul and he didn't talk about it.
He didn't articulate it,
you know,
he didn't wax poetic about it,
like cause state and
cause it was a great man,
but he did it that he did
right in front of my face.
And uh,
and it stayed with me.
You know,
I didn't understand a lot of it too.
I got older
but then suddenly I understood all of it.
Yeah.
And um,
so if somebody says,
hey,
you know,
I can't do this because,
last night my girlfriend,
my wife yelled at me and
she caught me with a girl.
She did.
I mean,
I don't want to hear it.
I don't want to eat,
And listen,
it was of course to me too,
in some ways it's not perfect
because when my father died,
I went to the,
I went to the funeral and then I went
to the gym and I didn't tell nobody.
And listen,
I probably shouldn't.
A lot of people would probably say he
can't live your life to way by what people
say.
I get it,
but I'm just saying I'm aware of it.
All right.
A lot of people who say you
shouldn't have went to the gym.
My father,
we lost a kid.
He was five years old and I wasn't going
to say this because I don't know how
some people say,
but if it is,
it is.
Right.
So you could take it the
way you want to take it.
I know the kind of man he was,
but
you talked about commitment,
absolute limits.
You'd talked about certain things,
right?
Maybe just to explain some of it.
We had little Todd,
he was all product.
He was born with problems.
Who's retarded?
You don't use that word anymore.
But in those days it was
okay to use that word.
That's what he was.
Okay.
Now of course you say
that it was impaired,
mentally impaired,
whatever.
Okay.
He's a beautiful kid.
I remember him.
I was older,
I was the oldest.
He was very loving.
I remember used to jump into
my arms when I come home.
So I know he was very trusting because
I would walk up the steps and he would
jump from the steps if
I didn't catch them,
obviously would have fell.
So it was part of his condition,
but it was part of his
lovingness and has his trust.
So when he was five years old,
he had to get surgery.
He had a problem,
was hot,
it was open heart surgery,
open heart surgery is all
different story back then.
Right.
And where did he get out of probation?
Yeah,
he did.
And my father's hospital,
but father did not perform the surgery.
Of course you're not going to do that.
But it was there.
There was a few surgeons,
it might've been five,
whatever it was.
And um,
my mother was the opposite of him.
My father was a Hungarian
Jewish background,
you know,
uh,
he,
he had no father.
He died young.
His mother,
they were very poor.
My mother grew up poor too.
Shoes,
Irish,
Catholic,
different makes.
And my father didn't
have time for religion.
My time for that time for living.
And for healing people.
So he let us be brought up Catholic.
That was up to my mother
and uh,
so he,
okay,
eh,
they were different.
They would the opposites.
When mother was beautiful,
she was Ms. Dot.
Nowlin uh,
her mother didn't let her father died.
Also young,
uh,
her mother was a tough
Irish woman and she,
my grandma,
she,
she did not allow her from winning.
Ms. Dot.
Announce was supposed to go to
them obviously to Miss America.
She wouldn't let it go.
I say right out,
she thought that was for horse.
Like,
like you go do that.
You know,
even though she wanted,
she led,
that was cute,
but now you're going to go miss America,
you're going to go,
no,
we're not.
She said,
no,
you're not doing it.
And she had a chance to go
and try out for the rock cats,
which most people are,
they know what they are,
the dance group and,
uh,
Radio City Music Hall.
Now that's for those people told them no.
So she was beautiful and she had
a great personality and she's,
she love social life.
And two is the antithesis of
my father and a lot of ways,
and I guess opposites attract and if
you want to make a movie out of it,
she was sick,
she wasn't getting better.
And my father was in the hospital,
he was in,
I guess his patient was in the tool room,
whatever,
whatever.
Then he became a doctor
and a help to get better.
She had a form of hepatitis,
um,
back in the days when you didn't get it
from needles only he could get it from
eating a bad clam,
whatever.
I don't know if it was c,
whatever it is,
I'm not going to tell you
because I don't know for sure,
but,
and she was very sick and anyway,
he,
he took care of her and they got married.
They fell in love and
in all of that stuff.
So,
you know,
just,
um,
my father was a
okay.
Like I said,
my father was,
he,
he was dedicated to,
uh,
to that life.
Uh,
but the thing that he did
that I started to say,
and I don't want to give
that background I guess,
but
my,
my mother was very emotional.
My father's a doctor.
He hid his emotions.
Okay.
And when Todd one for surgery,
he died on the operating table.
He had told my mother,
my father never lied.
Yeah,
he told her the risk.
But my mother want to believe
what you want to believe.
My mother said,
you said it would be okay.
No,
he didn't say that,
but you know.
But of course my mother,
my father was high level to
you know,
made her better.
It can make you sound better.
So he died,
we all got split up.
I had to live with an uncle that was
single and it was a very handsome guy.
So he had girlfriend coming in
and out all the time and you know,
lose.
And you know,
he was young,
good looking guy and like to go out.
I'd wind up sitting in
a bar waiting for them.
I get a lot of bags of potato chips,
a lot of cokes,
you know,
he could finally come back.
I have eight cokes in front of me,
maybe 10,
you know,
and um,
we got split up from my mother
was sleeping in a cemetery.
She had a nervous breakdown,
but you know,
she got herself together.
She overcame it.
But,
um,
she never forgave him.
Yeah.
You know,
and um,
you know,
she was Irish and then the easy thing
is to Irish cars and all that stuff,
but you know,
she trying.
But um,
okay.
She,
uh,
she's a great woman but you don't
see was tragically hard and you know,
everyone copes with things
differently and she,
uh,
it was,
it was difficult.
And that day with all of the,
what I just described,
and again,
I'm always afraid to say it,
but you say it because it's part of it,
right?
Maybe it explains,
maybe,
maybe some people hold it
against him when I say this,
but he got a phone call that
day on his answer and surface.
You didn't have pages in those days.
He had an answering service.
He told them to call them when
he had request for house calls.
Two in the morning as a kid,
I used to hear the phone ring.
It was two in the morning.
I started getting dressed.
I came out and I was on the
stairs waiting for the golf.
He looked at me,
what,
what are you doing?
I'm going,
which you know,
you're not kept back in the mall.
You know,
sometimes you let me go with them.
And um,
anyway,
this day,
obviously it was a
different day and there was,
his patient has patient's
daughter had a child who was very,
very sick.
She did not know that has son the mother.
No,
but the daughter didn't know
that his son died that day.
That his son was buried that day,
I should say.
So she called,
he went and did a house call on a day.
That is,
you know,
okay.
That his son got Barry.
You know,
that's tough.
But that was what,
you know,
that's what his,
um,
so when people tell me that
they can't keep a commitment,
this happened,
it doesn't go with me.
That's all.
And that day after I buried my father,
I went to the gym
and I trained Michael Moore
because I was,
you know,
that's what I was doing.
That was my job,
character,
real character.
I mean,
whatever it is it is,
but whatever it is,
that's true.
You know,
call it whatever name,
whatever noise you want to make.
There's not a lot of people like that.
That explains a lot.
Explains a lot about your unyielding
understanding and appreciation
of real commitment.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean that's,
that's,
yeah,
and it's,
we almost don't have a choice,
you know,
because to not
listen,
you just do it.
But to not follow that,
in some ways it's,
it's like you're not honoring your father
because your father's
leave you certain things,
you know,
they leave you,
something in the,
well maybe they'd leave your whatever.
They might leave your special trinket
of something that he always remember a
car,
a little thing,
whatever,
but they leave you something.
If you're fortunate
enough to have a father,
I know not everyone is,
I get it.
But when they leave you that
you,
you got to,
you got to cherish it.
You should.
And that's what he left me.
So to be,
it's not that I'm a good guy or bad
guy or great guy or less or anything.
I'm not,
I'm not any of that.
But I'm loyal to that because
you should be loyal to that.
Does that makes sense?
I mean,
you know,
I'm loyal to that idea.
I'm loyal to that living.
I'm a loyal to that,
that
to start stance that he
took and living his life,
that belief that,
you know,
principle of living,
whatever you want to call
a code of whatever you,
all those words that make it sound better.
But
I would feel that I,
uh,
by not doing it that way,
when you're lucky enough to have a man
that kind of torture what he taught you
without talking too much.
Um,
and I might be the greatest
teacher is by seeing,
right
examples it,
but if you don't honor that,
okay,
then you're not on your father
what he stood for.
And at the end of the
day I was pissed because
okay,
for everything that he did,
there's not,
there's no,
I know that sounds foolish,
but there's no statue of him.
And so,
and for me there should be something
because he did it his whole life.
You know,
we all have moments of,
of light,
of moments of
where we maybe worry about what's,
what's there,
when we're gone and where we're going.
And maybe we change and I've seen it,
I've seen it with friends,
I get it,
I understand that.
But where we start trying to
live differently because we,
we start wondering about
what's coming next,
when we're gone,
death,
whatever,
you know,
but what's there.
And so we start thinking
about that a little bit.
Maybe I've seen people influenced by that.
I have,
you have to,
I'm sure.
And he was not influenced by that.
It was just what he was.
He was that his whole life.
And the only thing that I can think,
because I try to put pieces
together a little bit of what he,
how he got that way and
all I know from people when he died,
you know,
patients come up to you,
they're great and they
want to tell you something,
you know,
and they,
they told me,
you know,
that they were porn on the
neighborhood and everything.
A neighborhood called Mirin is Harper
down by the water in stat now and rough
place,
you know.
And um,
okay.
They told me that his
mother was a tough woman.
She didn't have a tough woman
and they was three sons,
you know.
And they were originally
from day one born.
They were born here but she,
they were from,
from Europe,
you know,
and they had just,
you had to be with the mother.
The mother told them what they had to be.
She told each one what you're going to be.
The oldest was my father.
Like I was the oldest and Eugene,
you're going to be an orthodontist.
He became an orthodontist.
Very successful.
Raddled you're going to be an engineer.
Boeing aircraft.
Unbelievably successful,
lived in Seattle.
Theodore,
the oldest,
her favorite.
You know,
you're not supposed to have a favorite,
but it's real,
right?
You have favorites.
You're going to be a doctor.
My oldest son,
you're going to be a doctor.
He wanted to be a builder.
He wanted to build.
He did both.
He built over a hundred hours on stone.
He built tiff and things and
how the fuck did he do that?
He did it as he was a doctor.
How did he have the time he bought,
he had contractor,
you know guy that did it,
but he,
he did that cause that was his passion.
Well he did,
but no,
no.
She was smarter than him.
She was smarter than anyone.
He was supposed to be a doctor.
He was one of the greatest
diagnostic doctors ever.
I know.
It's my father.
I know the whole thing.
I get it.
But he really was.
You walked in,
he knew what was wrong with you.
There's a great,
again,
we don't know like the Babe Ruth thing.
We don't know the complete truth to it,
but there's a great legendary
story that a guy walked in,
he had been to Mayo Clinic,
he had been to John Hopkins,
he had been everywhere.
It was dying.
That's all they know.
He was dying,
losing weight for an apart,
dying and nobody could diagnose him.
He walked into this place where you had
to wait five hours to see him because
the line was out the door because he was
had all the poor people and there were
cigarette burns and all the rugs,
and she was like,
where am I?
But when you got to them,
you know where you are.
And he went there.
Somebody sent them.
They went there,
and my father may,
all the patients leave and
he gave himself an injection.
That's the legendary story.
And I asked him about it
and I as it was a name,
I couldn't tell you the name,
whatever.
He made it real simple.
He said,
because he knew I watched movies and we
all watched movies and we owe her things
from different times.
And he said back in those days it would
have been called leprosy was some kind
of cancer
and I guess there was a contagious portal,
whatever.
And he got everyone out of the office
and he diagnosed the guy came sofas shot.
He would give himself a shot.
Yeah,
yeah,
too I guess.
I guess so.
I mean that's the story.
Right.
And um,
he said to me though,
the only definitive thing
I know about that story,
and it was a million of them,
you know,
similar,
but was that I bragged to my fault,
you're smarter than all
these other doctors.
And he said,
Norma
and I said,
but you found it and these other plays,
big hospital,
big problem.
I'm not a big hospital.
Big hospitals,
bigger problems.
I said,
what do you mean they have to do things
fast and with large numbers I don't.
So they have to,
it has to make sense.
Some things don't make sense.
That's what he told me.
He said,
so this particular day,
they are smarter than me.
They knew the characteristics
of the disease.
They knew the symptoms.
They knew that it fit in here,
but that hadn't been around for 40
years in the continental United States
whenever he said to me.
But I remember it was something like that.
It hadn't been around for 40,
maybe it was 60,
but whatever,
it hadn't been around.
So they move right past that because
they had to go with a big hearts.
But Oh,
they got to go quick
because I don't have to,
he says it didn't make sense to
them because it was around 40 years.
But he says if it is almost
like of walks like a duck,
quacks like a duck,
maybe it's a doc.
So he just stayed,
he could stay with that.
They couldn't stay with that.
And he stayed with and who was right.
And um,
he did a lot of things like that.
He was famous for that.
He was famous for people coming
from Brooklyn coming from Manhattan,
common over there to see this diagnose
cystic genius in his little basement
office where people opt out the block,
like the Wayne for Mcdonald's or pizza.
And,
um,
and it costs less than
Mcdonald's to a certain extent,
you know,
because if we didn't have money,
didn't charge it like I said,
but he uh,
but he made money,
well of course,
but he didn't make the money of the,
and he was a,
I tell you a great story to be a,
to have a nursing home.
Maybe this explains him the
best to have a nursing home.
You had to have a open on stand on it,
I guess anywhere in New York he had
to have a doctor was signed on as the
medical director.
The problem was they couldn't
pay it because the nursing
homes won't really make
them money.
So you just had to have
a doctor would be there.
None of them really wanted to do it.
So my father was a
medical director and just,
just bear with me,
I'm going to say of eight nursing
homes might have been five,
might have been nine.
So I would go with them on house calls.
That's how I hung out with them.
So I go with them or nursing homes.
So of course he didn't get paid.
He was directed,
but he figured if he was that,
he never told me this,
but I think it's okay to say it.
He figured if I'm going to be there,
I'm going to go see the patients.
I'm not,
so he didn't have to,
but he went once a week and he went into
each nursing home and I went with them
when I was with them
and he saw the patients.
So there's one day we go in and he's like,
he gets treated like royalty.
I mean,
he comes in,
the staff comes running out
from all the nurse stays.
They all come on,
you know,
and it made me feel good.
I was like,
wow,
I'm with a man.
So I'm following them around.
We've gone down the hallway
and he's very humble.
He really truly is.
That word is overused,
but this guy was beyond the
humble like directed thing.
We'll go this way.
The the needle,
it was ridiculous.
He get mad if you said
some good about him.
So
they all colonies where he,
uh,
hey,
you have to charts.
Yeah,
come on.
So he's looking at the charge
to change his medicine,
give him 100 million,
you know,
the typical stuff that I know from
watching to Kildare or something.
Right.
So
looking,
you know,
and
he's doing his thing and he's going down.
I'm following him around.
I'm a,
I don't know how old I was,
but young 10
11 so I'm found more
of a sudden this woman.
Do you ever see,
I don't know,
I jumped around with these things,
but you ever see the movie?
It was like comedy guy that was around
back then and he did like a bride of
Frankenstein and he did Brooks.
Yeah,
it was one of his movies and
the bride of Frankenstein,
the white hair who was like,
well this woman was the of Frankenstein.
She comes running out and she was the
shelf and she was like half nude and Hogan
was falling off and she's an older
lady and her white hair was like that.
And she comes running and she's yelling
incoherent and screaming and they jump
and they jump.
When he started putting straps around the,
I guess like the old white coat,
I guess.
And they got,
apparently she was tied up to a bed,
you know,
obviously back in those days they
didn't know how to deal with,
see now people the way,
you know,
it was a whole different thing.
I mean,
we're talking a lot of years ago and so
they had a tied up and she got loose and
her gown was falling off and she's,
and uh,
so they jump up on her and they're tying
her up and I'm watching this woman get
mugged in the nursing home that my father
to the medical director of and all of
a sudden he said,
leave it alone.
And he's still looking at his charts.
He's not like,
oh,
hey Yo,
uh,
law,
but it's okay.
She's fine.
She'll be all right.
She calmed down.
She was a little nuts,
but
she was not spank.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a fair,
that's,
it's okay to say it's realistic.
And
she comes over to my father,
she says,
Hey,
and he's writing and he starts walking.
She starts falling.
Now I'm a kid so I can figure it
all out the way I could later.
Right.
But she becomes his assistant basically.
She's following him around and she,
he's going to room to room and she's,
see,
I think he gave her,
if I remember correctly,
he gave her like the,
the,
the thing that you write on a billboard,
you know the thing,
uh,
yeah.
Clipboard to hold.
So she's holding a clipboard and she's
looking like she's making beliefs,
she's reading stuff and,
and,
and I'm like looking at the scene,
like,
you know,
but I'm a kid,
like I haven't seen all the
movies yet that I can compare it,
that there's,
this is out there,
you know what I mean?
This is freaking nuts.
And,
and she found around,
she's looking at the thing
and I think she's like Zane.
Yeah.
Yes.
And he's going and he's,
he's basically not even
paying attention.
He's just,
every once in a while I said,
let me hit the,
and he's the,
and all of a sudden,
and this is the part again,
just like the other thing I
think about leaving it out,
but if I leave it out,
it's not a story.
It's not a story.
Because if I left it like that,
it's a beautiful story.
But this is a beautiful story in its
own way because there's is what it is.
It's a real,
he's in front of,
and my mother was,
I described as she was his gorgeous,
beautiful woman that like could things,
my father could give a crap.
My father had ink stains exploding
in his white shirt pockets.
My mother would go crazy.
He went to Kmart and avi,
remember Kmart,
he went to Kmart and borders
all shoes for four 99 each,
maybe three 90 [inaudible] plastic shoes.
And my mother was buying
him leather shoes.
He never warned them.
If he knew what she paid
for me would have went nuts.
Waste waste for what?
That was his,
that was him.
So he's got these plants
and shoes and you know,
he's got the inks blow up in
his pockets and everything else.
And My mother would always get upset,
always mad.
Why do you wear those shoes?
I,
yeah,
but he does.
So he's walking in front of her and
all of a sudden everything changes.
The woman goes,
he's neither doctor
he'd see.
She flipped on him.
Can you imagine this?
She could have to be in so great to her.
He's not a barely gets his
attention still walking.
He's not a doctor.
Everybody.
He's got holes in his shoes.
I looked down,
his foot goes up,
he's got a whole new shoes,
socks to out the shoe.
She was right.
He's got a hold of those freaking
show and his plastic shoe.
He doesn't care.
She,
he,
he can't be a doctor.
He's got holes in his shoes
now.
He turns around,
he looks at her.
I never forget this.
He pats her on her head,
says,
you're not so crazy.
Pats her on the head just like this
and neither in a demeaning way like you
might think.
You know what I mean?
Really?
He touched her on her head and said,
you're not,
you're not so crazy.
It turned around,
took the billboard and kept walking.
She didn't say another word.
Wow.
My mother was freaking embarrassed and
mad because I told the story when I got
home and of course he would never tell it.
And I said,
you know,
dad,
I said it like a kid would say,
you know,
this ladies said,
he's got a horse.
Oh my God.
You know,
Jesus,
you know?
Right.
Didn't meet anything.
Yeah.
Well that makes just
this your description,
your understanding of your father,
it just makes so much sense.
So much sense of who you are and why you,
why your principles are so rigid,
why you're,
you're intolerant of any bullshit.
Just makes so much sense
as a fight trainer and as a guy who
understands fighters is a commentator and
makes so much sense that you,
you have this just unyielding
need for 100% commitment.
Yeah.
I mean,
so just told her,
listen,
it doesn't make me a better
person or anything else to say.
I don't have tolerance for the BS.
Right.
Because I know it to be bs.
You know,
I,
I say to we,
we were running these gyms
in la for the last nine.
You're 22 years.
I've listened.
When he died,
I started to talk to Atlas Foundation
again.
There was no statute.
Okay.
So I really,
I went to a supreme court judge who was
a friend on [inaudible] because I used
to be in front of the judge is
when I was young and a bad way.
And,
uh,
because I got myself in a little trouble,
stupid,
you know,
but I got to the right place.
That's what counts,
right.
I think.
And,
um,
but,
uh,
I always got a kick out of it that I
could hang out with the judge and I didn't
have to be in a court to do it,
you know?
Right.
And I didn't have to be
standing like in front of them.
I could be on the side of like,
hey,
so,
um,
I've got a few people together and I
started the doc that was foundation to 22
years ago.
And,
uh,
we've grown quite a bit,
but just a little grassroots thing,
but it's grown.
Um,
we probably give away,
uh,
and real help.
We have one paid person and
one office has 1400 a month.
That's it.
Um,
so no administrative
costs other than nose.
And um,
that's it.
Nobody gets salaries to start one person
and all the money goes to the cases and
uh,
we probably give away.
Yeah.
600,000,
700,000 a year.
Um,
but direct help,
um,
we don't,
we don't give to the,
you know,
we don't give to march of dimes.
We don't give it to them.
We don't give it to
patients getting Red Cross.
We give it directly.
We've,
we,
they come to us now because we were
out there to an extent where people all
know,
but they,
they come to us,
they have a kid with cerebral palsy,
needs a certain bike,
the bike cause $1,500,
bang,
boom,
got the bike.
We got another way.
It needs a machine that
circulates the blood in his legs.
Of course.
25 hour bang.
You got it.
Well,
obviously we,
we make sure it's legitimate.
We research it,
we do that.
We have a board.
We make sure drill we do do make sure
it really is real because you do get
people to take advantage a little bit,
but,
and we do it.
We act on it because my father never
made people feel less when they were poor
or when they needed something.
That was the greatest thing he did.
He never made them lose
more than they lost already.
Their integrity.
Never.
Never,
never.
He never made him feel he didn't show.
I remember one time,
it was Christmas Eve when it was
I hanging out and I was a kid.
I was in them.
I was at my father's office because
I want her to be with them and it was
Christmas eve and it was late and we
were still in the office and a woman,
I remember she was a Spanish woman.
She came in,
she has six kids and she was nervous
and I remember watching how nervous she
was.
I was like,
even though I was young was like,
she's really nervous and I found out,
I learned about human behavior.
I learned about what it was and
I'm watching her and sure enough,
she was getting ready when the
last kid got taken care of.
She was going to dot out of there.
She didn't have money and the poor woman,
she was she,
she had to take care of her kids.
She didn't want to do that,
but she was going to run out of there
cause she did not have money and he
recognized me take announced
I didn't know what it was.
So I'm not going to say
I thought I was smart,
but I recognize something.
All this motion,
all this nervousness,
it wasn't normal.
He recognized at all and before he got
to the last kid so he wouldn't embarrass
her so she wouldn't run out of there
and do that to itself and lose something
more than she lost already.
He said,
this one's on me
and the nervousness went away.
She said,
there's no charge today.
He said there's no charge today.
And I don't know if she spoke English,
but she understood it and he made her
understand it and there was no charge
today.
And soon as he said that,
everything changed.
Everything changed.
He wasn't nervous,
he wasn't looking at doors and she's,
she cried
and she left and when she left,
the place was packed
because that was his office.
And all of a sudden he's,
I've talked to himself a little bit,
just,
just for a second.
I mean,
he didn't do this on my,
you know,
but he just like said,
it wasn't like that,
you know,
I wasn't thinking,
of course he wasn't taking it.
He didn't know it was Christmas Eve.
So he turns to me and
he gives me a mission,
a job.
He opened the,
it takes hours and he gives me a $50 bill.
He says,
go find that she's probably on a bus stop.
I ran out that door like I like,
I was given the greatest
mission in the world.
High felt so proud I could,
I ran,
I knew where the bus stop was.
I was going to run all of them,
but she was at the first
one down on Bay street,
right around the corner,
down block,
two blocks.
And I,
she's there.
And sure enough days she has done a post.
I went up to,
I said,
the doctor said it gives
you this and you know,
she looked at it,
she,
you know,
she was shocked,
but she,
she started crying again.
But I felt so good because like
I felt like I was part of it,
you know.
And um,
so I started this foundation and I said,
you know,
I needed help.
I said,
look,
we're going to do what he did.
No red tape.
No losing your pride.
People that fall through the cracks.
That's my father.
He was,
he was,
he had a phd in that.
All the people that fell to the cracks,
he took care of more.
I said,
we're going to take care of the ones,
you know,
muscular dystrophy,
great organization.
But two people out there,
no,
not a bad way.
But did you know like 87% goes to
administrative costs and like 4% goes to
research.
These people don't need
research in their life.
They've told me that.
I know it,
I recognize it.
You know what they need.
They need a wheelchair.
You know they need a handicap ramp.
Do you know what they need?
They can't medication paid for.
You know what?
They need the utilities to be kept on
when they're being shut off because they
can't afford,
you know what they need.
They need the back rent paid because
someone got sick and one of the people
working there had to quit the job and
they were going to be put into a shelter
with six kids.
So we pay the back rent,
we paid the utility costs,
we pay the cancer Medicaid,
we put the wheelchair
ramp up and we do those.
That's what we do and I'm
researching part of their life.
It's great.
That's hopefully comes so we could close
all these places down and our close
mine down first,
but right now they don't need research.
They need that.
They need help for their way of life.
Now for the quality of
life for that kid now.
So that's what we do.
How could someone donate
to this if they want to?
It's the dark that was said.
I'm real bad on a website.
Stuff on wake up caveman.
But it's the doctor.
Atlas Foundation W.
Dot.
www.atlasfoundation.com.
Yeah.
And M seven one eight nine eight Oh,
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
Seven 1898070371 person.
Yeah,
there it is.
That's it.
There it is.
All right.
We got it up there.
One time with the phone number is
(718) 980-7037 (718) 980-7037 and um,
so Dr atlas.com.
Yes.
There we go there and donate.
I'm sold.
Thank you.
Yeah.
This is a beautiful conversation,
man.
And not just about boxing.
And uh,
I think this,
uh,
this,
like I said,
it speaks so much to
who you are and why you,
who you are and why you
won't tolerate any bullshit.
Yeah.
It's like when you've
seen a guy like that,
it's Kinda make sense.
Are you still working with fighters?
You know,
it's funny.
Um,
no was the word and to a few
minutes ago to a few minutes ago,
I'm saying a few minutes,
but until a week ago,
maybe less,
maybe five days ago,
I've,
I've decided to train a fighter.
He's going to fight for the world
light heavyweight title to sample first
against the second
hardest puncher in boxing.
Unfortunately,
when she wasn't and um,
it's gonna be,
I think it's on showtime,
I think.
I don't even know because I didn't even
find those details out when they asked
me to train them first I was saying no,
and then my kids said,
dad,
at least give it a chance.
So I flew out to where he is in Oxnard,
California to meet him.
His name is Alexander.
He's a,
he's a Ukrainian Alexander Wasik.
I learned that you don't pronounce the G,
it's voltage,
but it starts with a g.
He's 15 year old,
12 nine galleys,
finding the second hardest puncher in
boxing or donors to Stevenson in Montreal
where you call it.
It's a tough fight.
Um,
they asked me if I would
train them at first.
Like I said,
I would say no 20 things the
hardest punch your inbox.
Wilder,
wilder,
the old times would say he hit you on
top of the head and fractured ankles.
That's hard.
And,
um,
Donna Stevenson is a hell of a puncher,
is the second hardest puncher in boxing,
lefthand southpaw on top of it.
And um,
when I flew out talks,
not to two nights,
it,
if I'm going to say I'm
either going to say no,
which my kids asked me not to.
So I said,
then I'll get a fly out and I got to meet
him and when we had lunch with him and
the manager to,
you know,
anyway,
I'm sitting with them.
I don't know what they are for sure.
You know,
the manager I knew for
a while in a business,
but for sure you don't know to,
you know,
and um,
I wanted to try to find out.
So the thinking was like,
you know,
you're here to find out things.
Probably tomorrow in the
gym and post we watch tape.
So those are the things.
But,
so I said to him right out,
I said,
well,
I'm here to see one thing first.
If you're a decent person.
And they were,
you know,
they were like,
that sounds,
you know,
maybe different,
because you know.
But I said,
I just want to have your decent perfect
cause I don't want to be around bear
people.
I just want to be around and
there's bad people out there.
I'm sure it's the way it is,
but I don't want to be around bear people.
I never did.
But now I definitely don't.
I want to be,
if I'm going to spend two months,
it's not easy in camp.
I want to be around someone.
I feel good about being around.
And so that's the first thing.
The second thing is too,
I think I can help them.
That was the second thing.
Yeah.
And Kenny be helped.
So when you go to talk
to someone like that,
do you watch a move?
What he'd seen his family,
first thing I did,
I want to wind up meeting his family.
He's got three young
kids and he's a husband.
And of course,
and I see a decent person.
And then now my watch film and um,
I see a guy that has ideas
that need to be added to that.
I think that's the best word.
They've got good ideas technically,
but they need to be advanced.
They need to be added too polished,
polished,
edited.
Yes.
And uh,
taking down the road a little bit.
And um,
I see a guy who behaves like a fighter.
That's where it starts for me.
Besides being a decent person,
he behaves like a fighter.
He got hurt.
He got dropped in a fiery
behave like a fighter.
You have to be able to a
fighter to be a fighter,
you have to be a fighter.
Right.
And,
um,
well you would know that better than most.
So he,
um,
and,
and there's one problem.
Every fight he gets hit at
least once really clean.
You can't do that with this guy.
Right.
He gets it more than once,
but he gets it clean.
You know,
I,
one time I used to fight him when I
was trying to Bradley actually was,
I said,
you religious.
Yeah,
I am.
And my own way.
I said,
listen,
I'm not into that.
I'm say,
I'm just using it as an example,
my way of saying,
I said I was brought up a Catholic,
I forget half the things they told me,
but I remember about
they'd use to teach you've,
I'm probably pronouncing her when
I'm going to need your help again,
but venial sins and mortal since the renew
or the little ones you can live with,
you don't go and see the guy
that's read the mortal ones.
You've got a problem.
I said,
the way you box you've,
you make it moral sense,
it the venial sins domain crap,
right?
But you're make it more than
once you're getting a hit,
clean,
unblocked,
solid punches that sometimes
you don't even see.
Like the providing the crop,
right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
So I said that's going to be corrected,
right?
So we corrected.
So how do you correct something like that.
You know what it is,
right?
You have to know what it is.
You have to see why he's getting hit.
But you gotta change.
You gotta change the technique of way
everything.
There's rules.
You got to it's life.
It's when you work with a garlic,
then you only have two months.
How much change can you
affect in two months?
I worked with Bradley for the right wheels
fight and he and he couldn't stand in
front of the guy and he went out and
he moved around the guy and you know we
were,
we were fortunate.
We did okay.
We made some change,
but I mean little things like,
I'll give you an example.
Rules,
rules,
simple things like where
do you 12 punch from?
I know.
I just,
yeah,
I 12 I know.
Don't throw jab from there because if
you're too close he could time you were
right hand and we weren't heard.
Jabbers to beginning of things.
Jack has to the,
you know,
it leads to good things.
It's a great point.
Yeah,
it is.
It's a terrible punch and so it's
a horrible punch of your throat.
The wrong distance.
You drove from a little too close.
Bang.
You get who we're right in no way.
You throw punches from love
talking to all he got here.
We're right here and we'll
provide the god he didn't.
All he knew was he got hit,
but he didn't know why you
through the lab took in front,
right hand is there.
Boom.
Get on a side,
troll punches from certain positions,
not allowed to draw punches are less.
They're from the right position
now you have to cause
would tell me you have to
coal over and over and over and over word
again til they can't do it
wrong if they want it to.
It's got to become a habit.
Right?
But you're not thinking about it where
it's a habit and that takes a lot of work
and that takes understanding what it is.
And it takes a lot of work.
You've got to be on him every time.
And it takes a guy,
they can put his ego in a pocket.
It's why you want to know,
do I have a good guy here?
Do I have a decent guy?
Because you're telling a guy who's
already made it to a certain level without
you.
He has,
and now you're telling them
this things that he don't know.
So he's gotta be willing
to be able to accept that.
And I'm
one of the things I like people that
are unselfish and look all selfish to a
certain degree.
But again,
it's degrees.
How tough are you degrees?
All fighters,
a tough degrees.
How does,
how selfish are you degrees?
And
the whole understanding was I
would go to Oxnard for eight weeks,
you know,
to train them,
but maybe I don't want to go to oxide,
but I'll go wherever I
take it gives to fight it.
The best chance to win the weather,
the time zone.
But the main thing why I go there,
he's got three young kids.
I'm not in the rocky movie.
I don't want to take them away from
those kids for those eight weeks.
Right.
That's not good.
So how many,
so I took two weeks to decide to them.
He kept calling to manage up.
He's a good kid.
He is.
And he kept calling them,
manage up and saying,
did you hear yet?
And of course he had,
so he's thinking like
a good person or like,
I shouldn't say good part.
He's taken like a person that
wants to get what he wants to get,
but at the same time,
here's where the good part comes in,
or the self less pot.
He says,
if I have to go to New York,
I'll go to New York.
A lot of fighters don't do that.
They want help,
but they want it on their terms.
Right.
He said,
if I have to go to New York,
I go to New York.
If I have to go to Montreal,
Canada,
Montreal,
please tell them that,
that,
that spoke to me,
that I had this kid,
that selfless too to that extent.
And I could see was training him before.
Um,
I don't know the name,
but it was a
decent guy.
He's 15 at all.
But uh,
but he felt like when,
you know,
when he got dropped in a fight and
we went back to the gym immediately,
that should be dealt with,
you know,
but it was back to just basic training.
I can,
rather than that specific,
you know,
it doesn't mean that the guy's not good.
Doesn't mean it just that
everyone deals with things.
Definitely.
That's all.
I mean it doesn't make me this or that,
but I just can do it the way I do it.
And I do it.
I look at film,
when I went to see him,
I had a couple of pages
written out already on things
I saw on film that he does
well that daddy would have to correct.
And the one thing that he has to correct
for this fight will be good if you
don't get hit,
I mean that'd be a damn good thing.
But the one really thing is you can't
keep coming back in front of the guy at a
certain distance giving them a shot
at you when he can punch like that.
And that's one thing he always winds up
localized right back in front of the guy
and there's gotta be other options,
other places to go.
You know,
I joke around,
I used to fund,
you know,
different examples of different analogies.
I say,
listen,
whether you had a mother,
grandmother and had somebody when you
were growing up told you don't hang out on
the corner.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Why?
Because nothing good can happen.
Well,
don't hang out in front of the guy.
Not the good can happen or can happen.
So we go from there.
You know,
it's a lot more to it.
Yeah,
he does.
He's a smart guy.
He's got a beautiful family.
And like I said,
it's a,
I'm so when do you start?
Because December 1st
December 1st horses to fight,
I have to make a decision.
I have to,
it's either going to be an
eight or a seven week camp.
Uh,
I,
I'm trying to feel,
I'm trying to find out
by asking them questions,
how quickly his body gets in shape because
I know it sounds funny to the average
guy out there,
but if it's a week too long,
it could be bad.
Yeah.
You know,
so,
and he's overtrained in his career.
So I wanted to try to try,
it's not an exact science
to have a feel for sure.
Be Age of seven weeks.
Did you monitor their heart
rate the rest of the world?
I have.
So we have that stuff
that we do that right.
Um,
to see if there were a ton of
pain when they wake up in the yes.
But you know what?
I depend on B.
I'm not going to stay and be asked you.
I depend on my eye more
than any three cm song down.
He seemed struggle.
And the trick is to not get there,
to try not to get there.
What are you doing?
You tell them to take a few days,
but I try to see it before I see what w
what I mean is if he had a hard day of
training,
I will just automatically
give him a light day or maybe
off the next day.
And like a lot of people
won't because they're afraid,
right?
You gotta work,
you gotta work.
Right.
And,
and,
but I learned not to be afraid of that.
Right.
So if I see he had a
real and he looked great,
you know what,
take off to wall or you sure take
off tomorrow so we don't get there.
Right.
To try to kind of like my
father like preventative.
I said this is a new
way of thinking though.
And it's such a smart way of thinking
because for the longest time,
everybody just wanted to be tough.
Yeah.
They just wanted to work harder.
But you got to work smarter.
Yeah,
you do.
Less is more,
you know that Sam,
but,
but sometimes it really is sometimes,
sometimes,
but sometimes not because some people
are fucking lazy and they're looking for
that easy way out.
You have to gauge that Jack to see it.
You have to know what you got to,
you know what I mean?
And sometimes the real discipline driven
guys are their own worst enemy in that
regard.
Yes.
Pushed too far.
And this kid has been,
again,
I'm not here to say what was,
but the kid has been in that place.
Right.
And that's why they're coming to me.
And again,
I'm no better than anyone,
but I will understand that.
So when you were,
when you were saying seven
weeks or eight weeks,
so either one when you,
it's either going to be,
so my first day,
it's going to be a Monday.
So the first day in camp in
Oxnard will either be October 8th,
or October 15th.
October.
We represent eight weeks,
October 15,
seven weeks.
And that would mean I
would fly in on a Saturday,
get myself settled Sunday,
watch tape with him,
um,
uh,
and then start Monday with
a structured schedule,
you know,
with the ability to change at anytime.
Because again,
you see,
right.
You know,
I remember years ago I
was training fighters.
You know,
I've been around 40 years already.
I remember been Gleason's when
I moved down to Gleason's,
you know,
many years ago,
30,
whatever it was,
maybe more 35.
Um,
so Gleason's was in Manhattan,
it's in Brooklyn output.
It was a man.
It was the place,
you know,
and it was two blocks from
Madison Square Garden.
It was kind of cool,
you know,
so,
um,
I'm trying to find it.
And I remember I was the first
guy there and not bragging or not,
but I mean you just,
I would make my guys drink
water and he old time guys,
10 guys,
not because they knew it from scientific
ed visit and say other than it was
passed down to them.
It was taboo.
It was just passed down
to the tall drink water.
It makes you weak,
you know,
you've got to be tough.
Don't drink wine.
So I was making my guys
not only drink water,
drink a half a gallon,
I mean drink a lot of water.
So I remember some of the old timers,
would they be like talking about me?
They'd be like,
it's a fixed this guy don't drink
or don't follow what he's doing.
Because some of the fighters who say,
can I drink some water and
get loan that water and,
and,
and know would it gives you cramps.
It'll make you,
are you kidding?
No.
Don't give you cramps if
you drink a large amount.
Very cold and yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You could go.
But now if we hydrate you,
it allows you to stay strong.
Try to drive a car because the
desert with no water in the radiator,
you might have a problem.
You might and,
and,
but I'm telling you and I'm
not so all I was afraid no,
but I'm saying that that place,
the thing was nobody drank water,
spit it out.
And I was making my guys drink
and right in front of me.
Do you know though,
what was the difference?
I knew by learning.
I knew my father,
my father,
um,
talked about the importance of water.
You know,
he was proud.
I was training.
He thought it was going to be a lawyer.
He went a little different but a,
he was proud that it,
so he would talk to me like he was like,
I just got a to Osmosis,
if that makes sense.
I just,
I knew,
I knew water was healthy.
I knew it was important that you had to
rehydrate yourself and yet you had to,
my father had a thing with
water to my father would make,
my father got involved in my
training in different ways.
Like,
if my fighter was feeling a little weak
or he had a cut and he was healing from
the cut by father would say,
set them down in the ocean.
Why Dad?
We're not taking a vacation
part of them in the ocean.
I said,
all right,
okay.
Let them go in the ocean,
let them soak cause his scar,
whatever you know is called,
let them soak it in the ocean and uh,
don't go to Coney island.
Thought that might not be good,
but
that might not heal you,
but change it might change.
It might be green when you come out,
you got something going on with the hulk.
But,
um,
no,
but so no,
he would tell me in a
series where he said 30,
um,
send you a fighter.
If he's a little of,
he needs to be revitalized a little,
set them to the ocean
that was swimming ocean.
Let them be in the sun and let them soak.
So whatever,
concealing the notion and,
and if he happens to swallow some water,
it's okay because I have no one wanted
to swallow the seawater and the worst
thing in the world.
My father said,
it's okay.
Not the worst thing.
So one day,
I guess I got around to asking him why
he was so into sending my fighters to the
ocean.
And he told me he was,
he just,
that's how my father would say things.
He would just tell me things
and that's where I would learn.
And he just said to me,
ocean is where all life came from.
All Life on earth started in the ocean,
microcosms,
whatever you want to call.
They didn't get into all technical stuff,
but he said it started in the
ocean and it came out onto land.
He says,
all percentage of salt in our blood is
the exact same percentage per skew begins
with a cubic gains.
You know,
whatever it was,
I'm just saying,
probably not close to what he said,
but close enough,
um,
is the exact amount cubic
inch as it is in the ocean.
We come from the ocean.
All life comes from the ocean.
Go back to where life came from.
That was enough for me.
My father was telling me anything.
My father told me that was it.
So I said,
all right.
So,
um,
so a matter of fact,
he told me his story.
I remember I was going out with a girl,
um,
that had a little baby that
had a Bolex and he told me,
he said,
and he was serious,
he wouldn't say it otherwise,
but he said send it down.
He had a condominium and they
told the beach and he said,
sent it down to Daytona Beach,
let them stay there for the summer and
let her boy being the ocean and the sun
vitamin a vitamin D.
Right.
I didn't know that.
Um,
and it is street and his legs out.
Yeah,
his legs or get straight.
They won't crazy,
you know,
but you know,
there was a cook in this to him.
His legs are good straight and he was
right because by being in the ocean,
by being in the sun,
vitamin A and d healthy,
of course,
I guess part of it was the swimming and
part of it was the ocean and part of it
was the sun,
but it was straight in his legs.
And I looked at he need him to the
point where you had to put braces.
No,
but was there was a slight issue was
the initial it was a dramatic no,
but did,
but he say work.
Yeah.
Was it right?
You know,
but we just think of braces,
you know,
obviously.
And um,
but yeah,
and it would heal.
He would say glitter cod.
Coney Ocean is salt water.
He owes the cut.
It will heal the clot.
A lot of fighters used to
soak their facing Brian,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well Joe Frazier did.
Did that really keep you that your skin
tough and protect you from cuts or is
that an old wives tale?
That's a little bit of that old stuff.
You know,
where we don't know.
Right.
But they believed it and so,
you know,
he'd smell like a pickle when he was,
when he was following with you,
get hungry in any hit
you a lot of talking.
But other controversial training methods,
like a weightlifting for the
longest time was thought to taboo,
taboo,
holy field.
The Mackie shall stone Mackey shell stones
training or Holyfield and moving him
up from a cruiser way to a heavyweight.
He you true.
And it was a very light heavy
weight at the beginning,
right?
Cruiserweight yeah,
we really essentially was and they just
pack some meat on them Michael Spinks
with Yup,
that's right.
Michael Spinks was really the first,
yeah.
When he fought Larry Holmes and Mackey
shall stone worked with Holyfield after
that.
That's right.
Right.
Um,
yeah.
Listen and Gleason,
I'm going to go back to
Gleason's the epicenter,
you know,
to place
no water,
no weights.
Right.
I got,
I used to have my fighters
to wait if I felt,
if I felt that a fighter wasn't
physically strong enough,
I put them on a weight program,
but I do it myself.
I would,
there was no strength coaches back then.
But,
but just the common sense
program three days a week,
you know,
eat protein,
of course you have to replenish yourself
with the proper diet and all that
stuff,
but,
and do it at the right time in between
the training where you're not killing,
you say overtraining.
Right.
You know,
go spar entire,
that's right.
You don't have to separation of workouts.
But if I had a slightly built guy that I
taught two things and the second one is
one where probably sounds a little that
you wouldn't have would normally connect
to it.
But the first thing was if I thought he
could physically be a little stronger,
not that he had to be fighting inside,
but when he did fight inside,
because that's face of your fighter,
you're going to wind up and walk quarters.
You are even though you say,
well I'm going to live on the outside.
Okay.
Until that day that the Guy
Slips Your Jab and again,
now you live in any inside.
Are you ready to live on
the inside for a minute?
So I believe that.
So I would make my guys two weights if I
told physically they could get help and
improvement in those areas.
But I also did it for
the psychological reason.
I felt that it's all psychological battle.
It's 75% psychological,
mental and you have to do any gene you
can to help to fight her in that area.
Anything,
anything,
grab anything that's if there's something
floating over your head are grabbing
anything and the mental part.
If,
if you make them feel stronger,
he'll be stronger.
If that's something that,
that just gives him a little I
older more of confidence and belief.
Now listen,
here's the,
here's the catch 22 maybe you
don't want the guy fighting inside.
Maybe his style,
his makeup is the fight I get to because
of the smart guys out there listening.
I'm sure there are.
They're going to think
that before he said it.
Yeah.
I still want them to feel strong.
Okay.
I'm not going to make,
I'm not going to make a guide that should
box like pinel where go was your box
like Muhammad Ali.
I'm not going to let them Mike
and fight like Jake Lamata.
I,
I'm okay with that,
but I want them to feel stronger.
I fought them.
What kind of weightlifting
would you have them do?
Because you're,
do you have a background in
lifting weights yourself?
No.
Other than I played football,
so he was around it.
And I've been around
Jim's my whole life and,
and fitness people all my life.
So I understand the plyometrics.
I understood all the advancements
or the new stuff that came out,
the bands that,
you know,
the,
hey listen,
you've got to remember there was a guy
named Charles Atlas that started with
resistance training,
who he was,
uh,
somebody kicked sand in his
face and his comic book.
Right.
And,
and you know,
I don't know if it was related or not,
but um,
but you know,
he,
he did isometrics.
I believed in Isometrix.
I did isometrics for the whole camp with
Michael Morell for the Holyfield fight.
Believe it or not.
Yeah.
I used to put my hand here and I used
to make him push against my hand,
but ways that we can push it,
I would design all kinds of different
exercises in ways to do it where I just
gave him resistance with my own body,
sometimes push against my shoulder,
you know,
and be careful.
The joints you won't in the,
you know,
all common sense stuff.
Yeah.
But,
um,
so we,
we,
this is something that
you thought of yourself,
you were trying to figure out how to
do it and then you just implemented it.
Yeah.
This is something that
a Michael Moore man,
when he was a light heavyweight,
was a murderous puncher.
Murder murderous boy.
Oh boy.
Woo.
He was dangerous.
He was so scary.
But it seemed like the
weight cut was too brutal.
Yeah.
It was brutal.
And,
um,
he was a terrifying light heavyweight.
Yeah.
He was,
I forgot about him.
They forgot about him
as a light heavyweight.
He'd knocked everyone out.
Just don't think he went
the distance with anybody.
He was murdering people.
Yeah.
He was really something.
And a first heavyweight,
uh,
first sao point,
heavyweight champ of whole time first.
Is that true?
Wow.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be true.
I've been saying,
I'm sure it is.
I didn't know.
Yeah,
no,
he was,
it could match them up.
Good person.
Very good guy.
Yeah.
He's like,
all of us,
we get lost and we get confused,
but he's a good,
you know,
you go to,
you're not good,
right?
Yeah,
he's you,
you want to hear crazy thing.
Um,
some people might,
I hope they don't.
Whatever.
I hope they don't take it the wrong way,
but anyway,
it's meant to be the good way.
Um,
I have a friend,
a very close friend.
I hate politicians.
I think they're phony,
but I have one that's,
he makes a live in a politician,
but he don't live as a politician.
Does that make sense?
I know he saying he's took
both president of stand on,
his name is Jimmy Hall and I'm probably
go crazy if he hears this put anyway.
It's okay.
He's a little crazy.
Anyway,
that's why we get along.
But he's a good man.
And uh,
like my father was born to be a doctor.
He was my,
my,
his mother knew it.
He was born to be,
I don't know,
I don't want to use the word politician.
Seems like a dirty word leader.
Yeah.
Aliyah.
Uh,
a carer of people.
All right.
I'm a public servant,
maybe whatever.
But anyway,
so he's the boat
president of Santa and he,
he really does things.
And,
um,
anyway,
we're close and he just gave,
is $94,000 for the foundation.
Like a week ago.
He does that.
He finds the money and you know,
he knows who he says is
the greatest compliment.
He goes,
I know.
It's called,
I know where it's going.
And,
um,
thank you.
He says to me and said,
what are you thanking me for?
Thank you.
I can't help these people without you.
You know,
I get all the help.
We do fundraisers and we do things.
We do a big dinner,
thousand people a week before Thanksgiving
where we have people like Tony Dancer
and Phil Sims and bill
pause cells use to calm.
He don't come no more.
He don't leave Florida anymore.
But,
but,
um,
you know,
we,
I mean,
uh,
Patrick Ewing to Campbell Mutombo uh,
I mean,
we're,
we're blessed.
We're blessed with Wolski Perez.
She loved pork.
She loves to have a,
I mean,
we were blessed.
Um,
Brandon Marshall from
the giants last year.
They come and they allow me to have a
successful dinner because they come and
they don't get a sense
because nobody gets upset.
And um,
so with all that in with Jimmy,
so anyway,
I have these things that
I just say sometimes.
So he caught me one time,
but I was just saying it,
I didn't realize that it
was going to register,
you know,
because it's just something,
so I just said
people bad.
So he said,
why?
I said,
well,
because what you say?
I said,
no.
you know what words to live by people bad.
So I've choking her.
But he said people bad.
So he said,
what do you mean?
I said,
Nah,
people bad.
He said,
but you help,
you're in a business.
I said,
there's good people too.
So anyway,
about a month ago,
two months ago,
whatever,
he comes up to me and he says,
you've got to think I'm out of my mind.
I said,
well,
no,
I know,
but for what?
What's the matter?
He said,
with your permission,
I want to take a domain,
which I barely know what that means.
Copyright to the phrase people bad.
And
if I told you I wanted to start a
business with you and me and the proceeds,
some of the proceeds will
go to the foundation.
We sell shorts would do that.
And you have these different sayings.
So to start with people,
bad
resiliency,
good people,
bad forgiveness,
bad be better people,
bad parks,
good
people,
bad,
you know,
redemption,
good people bad.
That's be bad,
you know,
whatever.
But the whole idea is to be unapologetic
and to say we got a problem.
I don't know if you want to
say we're at a tilting point,
but we got a problem.
If my as social genius,
no am I is saint.
No,
but I got kids.
I care about what the world is.
You know,
maybe if I didn't have
kids that still care
and I have grandchildren now,
I have two of them.
They're beautiful.
And you know what,
there's a lot of bad people out there.
I'm not apologize or about saying that.
There's a lot of great people,
there's more good people,
but it's,
it's like turning a battle line,
a line of resistance.
Really.
Where I want to call people out on it.
I want to remind us
that we could be better.
I want to remind us that
people bad selfishness,
worse.
And,
and I,
I just want to too.
He brought my attention to it because
I used to use that phrase so frequently
when I was mad and he said,
that's turn your med
into something better,
teddy.
That's debts because I
know what you stand for.
I know I,
that's why I give you
what I give you 22 years.
So people are bad,
but they,
they're good.
They're good.
That's remind people
that we need to be good,
that remind people,
that's called them on a crap.
That's that we can say,
hey,
we gotta be better.
We've got to care about the right things.
We've got to stop getting
caught up in our crap.
You know,
and we gotta be stronger people.
Bed.
Don't be weak,
you know.
But in other words,
we're using it to,
to remind people that
sometimes we'll go in,
in a bad direction.
We are,
look at the world,
look at that.
You know,
when I was flying here was
reading the New York Post.
Do you know how when people
think of week or something,
but I didn't want to read some of the
stories about some of these kids that got
killed.
It,
there was a story about a parent that
someone at a hospital in Manhattan that
decided to slice up a bunch of infants,
um,
just ran to the hallway of tos.
His place was for Chinese immigrants that
they go to this place where now young
mothers where they think it's a safe haven
for the children to be there for like
a month.
And so they infants two days old,
five days old,
10 days old,
and they're all in.
It was all Chinese immigrants
and they're all in there.
These babies and this woman walks in there
with a knife and start stabbing these
kids.
Now listen,
I know a lot of people
out there going to say,
teddy,
that's psychotic.
That's different.
I,
yes,
it's evil.
Yeah,
there's evil in the world.
but I'm just,
I'm just calling to arms.
I'm not the guy,
but I'm just saying in my
small way called arms that
we can be better.
That just remind people that,
you know what,
we have so much promise.
There's so much to be
grateful for in this country,
particularly in the world,
but not always.
And we have so much here that's be better.
If people bed that's help them be better,
that's lead the way to be better.
Uh,
that's,
that's take a stance.
So we're going to,
I don't know how the frick
we're going to do it,
but we're going to start this company,
people bear,
but then we're going to have
all these inspirational,
if you will,
but all these positive,
positive,
positive
things to say that,
to remind you that in a way you
could be anything you want to be.
You know,
that old saying you could
be anything you want to be,
but some people choose to be bad.
True is to be better.
And um,
so we're going to do some,
the,
some of the proceeds go to the father.
I don't know how the freak
were probably whatever,
but we're going to figure it out.
Um,
he's going to do it all
because I only know boxing.
I think you know more than that.
Listen,
Teddy,
there's been three hours.
I'm sorry.
Don't be sorry.
It was great.
I really appreciate you being here,
man.
Wow.
I know.
It's actually a little bit
more than three hours and,
uh,
thanks for,
it was beautiful.
Thanks,
man.
Thank you.
Appreciate you.
Appreciate you and Teddy Alice,
ladies and gentlemen.
Hm.